So, erst noch ein bisschen Tee, so, wir müssen Hydrated stay in.
Oh, was ist denn das?
Ich sehe gerade vor meinem zweiten Kopfhörer geht die Ohrmuschel langsam ab.
Echt?
Wo macht das denn sowas?
Gut, das ist so ein billig 30 Euro Kopfhörer, der hat schon lang genug gehalten, das reicht
eigentlich, das war sein Geld wert, ja.
Und zwei Leute schon da, Fips ist immer am Start, weiß auch nicht wo er immer herkommt,
der ist immer schon da, bevor der Stream online ist.
Oh, jetzt warten wir erstmal bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass der Stream online ist, oh ja, oh,
es ist ganz schön kalt, oder, heute Nacht?
Kurz Wetter gucken, ja, es ist immer noch kalt, ein Grad, krass, wenn man sich überlegt,
ich bin vor vier Tagen noch in kurzer Hose rumgelaufen, das ist schon echt heftig, überlegt
mal, von kurzer Hose zu ein Grad draußen, null, im April, das gibt es auch nicht oft,
Außentemperatur 2,7 Grad, sagt mein Thermometer auf dem Fensterbrett im Schlafzimmer, Samstagnachmittag
hat abonniert, danke schön für den Sub, es ist doch nicht Samstagnachmittag, sondern
Sonntagvormittag, du hast ja deinen Account erstellt, Samstagnachmittag, oder, und warst
unkreativ, was du nehmen sollst, Serious Marks, danke schön für den Sub, 21 Monate,
ich brauche unbedingt neue Subscription-Kekse, weil nach dem Gold-Keks gibt es nichts mehr,
und der Gold-Keks ist für 12 Monate, für ein Jahr, glaube ich, wir brauchen noch mehr,
wie gesagt, der Rolex-Keks, wir brauchen noch einen diamantförmigen Keks, keine Ahnung,
mir fällt gerade nichts besseres mehr ein, Emote-Slots, boah, viele, 14 oder so, alles
in allem, 14 Emote-Slots oder so, wer macht die Artwork-Stack, ich selber, nein, nein,
nein, also die Kekse sind von, Moment, ich muss gerade mal das Profil suchen, die Kekse
sind von ihr, die hat die Kekse gemacht, und die macht generell ziemlich nice Emotes, also
wer was braucht, ihr habt die Emotes gemacht, ich selber, wenn ich die selber gemacht hätte,
dann würden die so aussehen, was auch so würden meine Emotes aussehen, wenn ich die
Emote selbst gemacht hätte, Kek, jeder was er kann, jeder was er kann, ich kann garantiert,
also wo ich ganz schlecht bin, ist grafische Sachen, ich mache meine Thumbnails mittlerweile
selbst, warum mache ich die selbst, weil alle Thumbnail-Leute unglaublich unzuverlässig
sind oder man sich mit ihnen nicht über den Style einig wird, weil das sind sicherlich
nicht die krassesten Thumbnails der Welt, aber immerhin, ich meine irgendwie sehen sie
halbwegs einheitlich aus, man kann sie sich angucken, ey es ist krass was man mit Paint
machen kann, es gibt ja richtige Wettbewerbe, also wo mit Paint Sachen erstellt werden und
die sind teilweise huge, also die, es gibt richtig mega ultra krasse Paint-Dinger, aber
auf der anderen Seite, ich meine wenn man sich überlegt, man kann bei Paint einzelne
Pixel einfärben wie man will, das heißt potentiell kann man mit Paint jegliches alles erstellen
was man erstellen will, die Sache ist halt nur die, das ist halt sehr aufwendig und kann
nicht jeder.
Na das ist so wie wenn du sagen würdest, also um mal Paint mit Game-Engines zu vergleichen,
du kannst mit Paint alles machen, weil du Pixel unterschiedlich einfärben kannst,
das ist wie wenn du sagen könntest, wenn du eine Game-Engine hast, die nichts anderes
kann als Get-Pixel, Set-Pixel, Color und Koordinaten, kannst du damit alles machen,
das mag zwar streng formell genommen richtig sein, praktisch wird es dir aber nichts bringen.
Obbei nichts anderes ist ja das was man mit Shader-Programmieren für Grafikkarten macht,
weil du sagst im Prinzip wo der Pixel ist und welche Farbe der Pixel hat, nur dass du
da halt ein bisschen mehr drumherum noch machst.
Hattest du schon mal das Thema Programmieren in Paint, nein ich wusste nicht dass man
in Paint programmieren kann.
Komm ich muss mal kurz husten oder?
So.
Es gibt Sprachen die auf Grafiken setzen, dann gibt es geistesgestörte Leute die dann
echt in Paint Kästchen zeichnen müssen, mich wundert nicht mit nichts mehr er.
Hattest du die Sprache Pete, denn ich kenne Pete Smeet aber ich habe keine Ahnung was
die Sprache Pete ist, aber ich meine es gibt alle möglichen esoterischen Programmiersprachen
von Brainfuck bis Whitespace, ja schick ruhig, ja ansonsten, zeig mal kurz, Programming in
Paint aus 27, pass auf jetzt kommt irgendein Toss-Video oder so, ok was, was genau bin
ich sehend, was zum, ach es gibt irgendwas was dann Bilder ausführt oder so, ja das habe
ich schon mal gesehen dass es das prinzipiell gibt, Moment was, Moment man kann Bitmaps
so anordnen dass wenn man die als ASCII Zeug interpretiert dann das gültiger Text ist,
das funktioniert, das wusste ich doch nicht, ich meine auf der anderen Seite warum nicht,
ich meine BMPs das sind Gruppen immer aus 3 Bytes für die Farben, das kann man natürlich
auch als ASCII interpretieren im Endeffekt warum nicht, das kann ich mir vorstellen,
ich meine der Header ist natürlich oben da, der Bitmap Header, aber trotzdem, das ist
ja wir, das ist ja, das ist ja wir, habe ein Video gesehen wo jemand ein komplettes Video
spielt einem QR Code, das habe ich auch gesehen, ja das habe ich auch gesehen, ja
das habe ich auch gesehen, so schauen wir mal was haben wir denn hier auf YouTube, was
können wir uns dann schönes angucken, LevelCaptchiebaited uns bestimmt gleich mal wieder, LevelCaptchiebaited
100 of Che, oh nee please, das ist doch, nein nein nein nein, wir lassen uns nicht Chebaten,
ich weiß genau was er erzählt, er wird erzählen von diesem komischen, wie nennen sie das
Battlefield Community Communications oder irgendwie sowas, wo sie gezeigt haben was
sie theoretisch machen könnten vielleicht in Battlefield, nee nee nee nee, kein Chebait
außerdem ist das nicht Week in Gaming, sondern das ist Today in Gaming, der hat Week in Gaming
noch nicht fertig, vielleicht kommt irgendwann Week in Gaming, da gucken wir das, aber ansonsten
gucken wir das nicht, heute kein Chebait, heute kein LevelCaptchiebaited, nein, du meinst
hier Slash, also Reddit Plays oder was, meinste, wo die Leute eben in diesem Canvas rumgemalt
haben, ah ok, Windows 10 Setup ist richtig Pengamon, die spammen jetzt ein so zu mit
Müll, wirklich, also noch mehr als vorher, ja wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich schon, wahrscheinlich
schon, DICE hat ja auch gesagt sie werden wahrscheinlich relativ, also gesagt, gesagt
das haben sie nix, es wurden interne Sachen geleakt, die wahrscheinlich stimmen, weil
die anderen Sachen die geleakt hatten auch schon stimmten, dass die vieles wieder rückgängig
machen wollen, aber das ändert nix, die haben keine Leute mehr, die Plan haben, wie man
ein gutes Battlefield macht, die spawnen nicht einfach jetzt dort und sie wissen wieder Bescheid.
EA Play Canceled, ja E3 ist auch Canceled und wisst ihr was man in Corona gesehen hat,
man hat während Corona gesehen, dass die ganzen Messen, sei es Gamescom, E3 und sowas
eigentlich total überflüssiger Kram sind, überflüssiger Kram, so irgendwie ein Relikt
der Vergangenheit, so, niemand braucht diese Messen, die sind jetzt nicht da und es hat
sich nichts geändert dadurch.
Weil ich meine ernsthaft wer braucht diese Messen, Gamescom war so ziemlich das unsinnigste
Event aller Zeiten, was bin ich, was sehe ich denn hier, ich lasse das mal nebenbei
laufen, oh das ist schick, hat er das selbst 3D gedruckt, dafür sieht es eigentlich ziemlich
gut aus, ich wüsste nicht genau wozu man das braucht, aber es sieht cool aus, oh sogar
mit Touch, guckt euch das mal an, richtig advanced, nice, ich hätte keine Ahnung wozu
ich das brauche, aber es ist nice, es sieht cool aus, ja, also die Gamescom war mit das
unsinnigste Event aller Zeiten, weil im Prinzip du konntest da hingehen aus 2 Gründen, entweder
weil du dir neue Spiele angucken wolltest, dafür war die Gamescom ziemlich sinnlos,
du konntest dir im Prinzip keine Spiele angucken auf der Gamescom, das sei denn du möchtest
auch für kleinen Scheiß irgendwie 2 Stunden anstehen, oder du bist hingegangen als Community
Event, weil du vielleicht deinen Lieblingsstreamer sehen wolltest bei irgendeinem Event oder
weil du vielleicht dich mit Leuten treffen wolltest oder so, das ist ok, das kann ich
verstehen, aber die Gamescom als Gaming Messe an sich, also für Games ist eigentlich ziemlich
sinnlos gewesen, der einzige Grund warum ich da ein paar mal hin bin ist, weil wir halt
im Vorfeld Termine gemacht haben, sodass man nicht warten musste, und ich kam mir da teilweise
schon echt ein bisschen Assi vor muss ich sagen, wir hatten am ersten Tag Termin ausgemacht
damals noch mit Nvidia für irgendeine VR Geschichte war das, da konnte man dann damals
diese Portal Demo, ich kenne vielleicht noch diese Portal VR Demo, die war eigentlich
ziemlich nice, das da genau, wo dann der Boden so aufklappt, irgendwann klappt dann
zwischendurch der Boden auf und du denkst so WTF was geht jetzt ab, konnte man da spielen
und zumindest, die haben uns einen Gutschein gegeben für den Stand und wir sind da halt
am ersten Tag später hin und da war halt schon eine Schlange, zweimal um den kompletten
Stand rum, das heißt die Leute haben da gestanden, mussten zwei Stunden warten und wir sind
hingegangen mit dem Gutschein und die haben uns direkt dran genommen, ich kam mir da schon
ein bisschen Assi vor ehrlich gesagt, gibt Leute die finden das bestimmt nice, die dann
quasi denken so nach dem Wort, haha guck mal hier, ich bin der krasse Influencer, komm
mal mit meinem Gutschein, schaut alle her, ich habe einen Gutschein, ich gehe da jetzt
rein vor euch, aber ich kam mir ein bisschen doof vor muss ich ehrlich sagen, vor allem
die gucken dich natürlich auch alle noch ein bisschen merkwürdig an, so nach dem Motto
Alter was ist das für ein Spaß, warum darf du da jetzt rein und ich muss zwei Stunden
rumstehen, finde ich auch nicht gut ehrlich gesagt, die haben im Zweifelsfall immer noch
die Möglichkeit das in dieser privaten Business Area zu machen, wenn man wirklich irgendwas
zeigen will und da ist es ja auch ok, aber ganz ehrlich, ich finde generell auf dem
normalen Gamescom Gelände sollte dann irgendwo gleiches Recht für alle sein, ja ok ich verstehe
das ist natürlich schwierig, weil du willst irgendwelchen Influencer Leuten und irgendwelchen
Gaming Leuten das natürlich zeigen und die haben auch keine Zeit den ganzen Tag rum
zu stehen, na dann solltest du im Kleinen machen in der Business Area, ich finde das
mega Assi, wenn du Fans hast die da hingehen und quasi das alles selbst bezahlen, selbst
ihren Aufenthalt planen und alles und sich anstellen und tun und machen Eintritt bezahlt
haben, dass du die dann da irgendwie zwei Stunden warten lässt, wenn es zwei Stunden
Wartezeit ist, dann sollten es zwei Stunden für alle sein, zumindest im normalen öffentlichen
Bereich, ja in dieser Business Area kannst du dann machen was du willst, ich habe mich
damals jebaiten lassen von Assassin's Creed Unity auf der Gamescom, wir hatten Termine
mit Community Managerin von Ubisoft und da konnte man sich dann aussuchen was man sehen
will und ich war so blöd und habe Assassin's Creed Unity genommen und das einzige was man
davon gesehen hat war irgendeinen komischen Trailer mit Fake Gameplay, wo nicht mal live
gespielt wurde, das war richtig jebait, ich meine ich hatte die Auswahl mit ihr zu Let's
Dance, ne nicht Let's Dance, wie heißt das, wie heißt dieses Tanzspiel von Ubisoft, hab
schon wieder vergessen, wollte da auf keinen Fall hin, Public Dance auf der Bühne, alter,
ich hab vergessen wie es heißt, Just Dance, Just Dance, genau, also ich hatte die Auswahl
mit ihr zu Just Dance oder Assassin's Creed zu gehen, da war ich halt blöd und hab gesagt
ich nehme Assassin's Creed, ich hätte lieber eine Runde Just Dance machen sollen, das
wäre im Endeffekt besser gewesen und außerdem wer wollte nicht schon immer mal vor allen
Leuten Just Dance machen auf der Gamescom, der Fabian, der Fabian hätte damit überhaupt
keine Schmerzen gehabt, sag ich euch, der hätte abgedanced auf der Bühne ohne Pause,
das sind übrigens auch die einzigen Spiele auf der Gamescom, die wenig Wartezeit hatten,
die Spiele wo du auf die Bühne musstest, da konntest du hin und du bist mehr oder weniger
direkt drangekommen, wollte halt keiner machen, wer erinnert sich noch an den Ticketkopierskandal
mit Isle of Cookies, meine Güte, was da wieder für Kram gelaufen ist, Keg Weight, so, ich
bin da, so, alles klar, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an, würdest du halt nochmal auf
Messen gehen, die Cebit war cool, auf der Cebit war ich leider nur ein einziges Mal
früher, die gibt's ja nicht mehr, das ist auch so was, wo Standort Deutschland das massiv
verkackt hat, die Cebit war mal quasi eines der, so wie sagen sie, am bedeutendsten, wichtigsten
und eigentlich nicesten Messen, aber dann hat's verkackt, irgendwie ist es in der Bedeutungslosigkeit
verschwunden, ne, ich würde nicht mehr hingehen, deswegen war ich auch die letzten Jahre auch
vor Corona nicht mehr auf der Gamescom, das ist einfach unsinnig, du erfährst die Sachen
schneller, wenn du den Livestream daheim guckst, als wenn du vor Ort bist, die einzig coole
Sache ist, dass man sich mal mit ein paar Leuten treffen kann auf der Gamescom, die man sonst
so gut wie nie sieht, das ist auch der, der eigentlich, und ihr wisst, ich hab's nicht
so mit Real Life und Leute treffen, aber das war sogar für mich so einer der wenigen nicen
Aspekte, dass man bei ein paar Leuten über den Weg läuft, ja, die man sonst nur online
kennt, aber ansonsten war da, war da echt für'n Arsch, ja, komplett, komplett useless
eigentlich, naja, neues Michael, neues Video von Michael Reeves gesehen, nö, das ist bestimmt
einer von, von den 20 Millionen Subscriber-Channels, die ich nicht kenne, was schauen wir uns
denn jetzt an, zeig mal hier, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten, Level Cap will uns debaten,
das machen wir nicht, April 2022, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, informatiker werden, ich
wäre Hacker-Angriffe ab, ok, das klingt doch schonmal nicht schlecht, das müssen wir uns
jetzt angucken, da bin ich, da bin ich mal gespannt, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob
dieses Video quasi wieder fernab jeglicher Realität rumgelaber ist, oder ob das wirklich
was damit zu tun hat, ja, was hat er denn hier für super advancedes Wireshark, das ist
das, was ist das, ist das Data-Doc, oder was ist das, oder ist das, ähm, irgendein Kubernetes-Panel,
keine Ahnung, kann ich jetzt grad nicht zuordnen, Elastic Search, das könnte auch sein, ich
weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ist doch wurscht, ein normaler Arbeitstag, ein großes Start-up,
widerspricht sich das nicht irgendwie, sind Start-ups nicht per Definition klein, weil
ansonsten wäre ja jedes große Unternehmen, was sagt, wir sind jetzt super krass agil
und dynamisch auch wieder ein Start-up, ich dachte Start-ups müssten klein sein, dass
sie Start-ups sind, ok, Laptop-Aufklapp, oder oft auch schon irgendwie beim Frühstück,
ja, das macht ja eigentlich jeder, und dann leg ich mir so ein bisschen einen Plan zurecht,
das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum so viele Unternehmen mittlerweile auf Firmen-Handys
und so, dass das bezahlen und gut finden, weil die genau wissen, die Leute gucken außerhalb
ihrer Arbeitszeit aufs Handy und wir haben davon was, alles schaffen möchte, ich bin
Mitarbeiter Nummer 60 ungefähr, inzwischen sind wir über 2000 Mitarbeiter weltweit,
ok, weiß ich nicht, kann man sich darüber streiten, ob das jetzt als Start-up durchgeht
oder nicht, also ich mein, klar kann man sagen, wir sind halt super agil und dynamisch und
deswegen Start-up, aber ich weiß nicht, 2000 Mitarbeiter ist doch schon weit über Start-up
eigentlich raus, oder?
Ich würde uns immer noch als Start-up bezeichnen, weil das für mich weniger mit der Unternehmensgröße
als so mit der Art des Unternehmens zu tun hat und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, lass ich
mir gefallen, wahrscheinlich bedeutet das für ihn, Start-up bedeutet wahrscheinlich
für ihn, zwölf Stunden am Tag arbeiten und klar, was verdienen, arbeitet und wie die
Leute und die Kultur ist, Lukas, danke für eine Zapp, na also ich hab jetzt in 15 Minuten
das erste Team-Meeting, da suche ich mir einfach, was als Netzwerk, als Netzwerker, Teamleiter
von 10 Programmierern, ok, na also ich hab jetzt in 15 Minuten das erste Team-Meeting,
da suche ich mir einfach irgendeinen Raum und dann hol ich mir vielleicht noch einen
Kaffee und dann geht's los, Homeoffice gibt's nicht, das ist zu Start-up, Ceylonis hilft
im Prinzip Unternehmen dabei ihre Prozesse effizienter ablaufen zu lassen, nahezu in
jedem größeren Unternehmen heutzutage läuft ja schon sehr viel digital ab, oh je, irgendwelcher
BWL Prozess-Stonks-Kram und Moment, Moment, Sekunde, das muss man sich nochmal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen, viel digital ab, ja Moment, Moment, hier das hier, heutzutage
läuft ja schon sehr viel digital ab, ja in Deutschland nicht, was wahrscheinlich ihr
Vorteil ist, dass ihr den Kram deswegen verkaufen könnt, was ja auch gut ist, das ist übrigens
eines der Gründe, hab ich gelesen, ist schon ein bisschen her, vielleicht nicht mehr aktuell,
ich war ein Jahr oder so gelesen, warum es aktuell in Deutschland ein relativ guter Standort
für Technik, also Technologie, Neukündungen, Start-ups und sowas sein muss, liegt daran,
nicht etwa weil der Standort auf einmal super attraktiv und geil ist, sondern weil ganz
viele alteingesessene Unternehmen eben die Digitalisierung gnadenlos verpennt haben,
d.h. die ganzen Start-ups, die kümmern sich nicht um, wie soll man sagen, neue innovative
Sachen, sondern die kümmern sich darum, die alten Dinosaurier für das neue Zeitalter fit
zu machen, mal gucken wie lange dieses Geschäftsmodell noch gut geht, hab ich gelesen, ich verfolge
so Business-Scheiß nicht großartig, hab ich vor über einem Jahr gelesen und klingt auch
irgendwie passend, oh ja, was mein Team macht, das ist so komplett hinter den Kulissen, jeden
Tag schieben die Kunden tonnenweise neu, hey, die haben den exakt gleichen Tisch wie wir
auf der Arbeit, exakt diesen Tisch haben wir auch, Tag schieben die Kunden tonnenweise
neu, aber ganz genau denn, Unifire X ist ein Poinsett-in-the-Count, dementsprechend müssen
wir immer dafür sorgen, dass die Infrastruktur weiter wächst, aber gleichzeitig dürfen
natürlich nicht die Kosten explodieren, also wir müssen schon noch ein bisschen schauen,
dass wir das einigermaßen effizient machen.
Ganz einfach, nicht vertikal, nicht horizontal, sondern diagonal skalieren, dann ist man so
scalable, da ist man fein raus, ihr wisst ja, also chat, ihr wisst ja, ich skaliere prinzipiell
seit Jahren nur noch diagonal, also dreidimensional sozusagen, diagonal, dreidimensional skaliere
ich, dann hat man quasi den Effekt von vertikal, horizontal und nach oben, das Team kümmert
sich um alles, naja, wenn es jetzt ein echtes Start-up wäre mit 10 Leuten, dann würde
ich das verstehen, aber ansonsten, du scales durch die vierte Dimension, ja gut, das ist
ja kein Ding, jeder scales durch die vierte Dimension, weil du fängst jetzt an und irgendwann
bist du fertig scaling, dann hast du ja automatisch durch die vierte Dimension gescaled.
Ich habe jetzt leider nicht so genau zugehört, Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz anhören, das Team
kümmert sich um 100 das Server und die großen Mengen an Kunden, ja, aber warum hat er dann
ein Team von 10 Programmierern, das klingt mir eher, wie gesagt, nach Netzwerktechnik
bzw.
Netzwerker und vielleicht Apartments, egal, das stimmt, die Access Points sind eigentlich
für die Decke konzipiert, aber das kann durchaus sein, dass das, je nachdem wie die Gebäudesituation
da ist, dass das nicht geht, auf der anderen Seite, wenn es ein 2000 Mitarbeiterunternehmen
ist, dann, ja, ach, was auch immer, das ist ja kein Büro, sonstwo irgendwie in einer
Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung, wie manche Startups, das ist ja wohl wirklich hier in Büro-Space
gemietet.
Okay.
Will ich nicht die Kosten explodieren, also wir müssen schon auch ein bisschen schauen,
dass wir das einigermaßen effizient machen.
Genau, dann wähle ich mich jetzt mal ins Team-Meeting ein.
Was ist das?
Wir nutzen da eben so eine ganz coole Lösung, das ist wie so ein kleines virtuelles Büro,
ein bisschen wie so ein altes Gameboy oder Nintendo.
Alter, das brauche ich auch.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Nintendo-Spiel.
Jeder in meinem Team hat so einen kleinen Charakter und wir haben hier.
Das brauche ich.
Was ist das?
Wie heißt das?
Moment mal, wie heißt das?
Das brauche ich auch.
Das muss ich bei uns auf der Arbeit vorschlagen, Sack.
Das ist wie so ein kleines virtuelles Büro, ein bisschen wie so ein altes Gameboy oder
ein Nintendo-Spiel, jeder in meinem Team hat so ein.
Sieht man irgendwo am Anfang, was das ist?
Habbo?
Hier.
Geyser.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein eigener Service, ich dachte, das gibt es als Teams-Plugin oder sowas.
Ja, aber das finde ich geil.
Das hat was.
Das hat was, das mag ich.
Workventure gibt es auch, okay.
Ja, das ist cool.
Also ganz ehrlich, das werden wir auf der Arbeit nie einsetzen, aber das fände ich
geil, hätten wir das.
Arbeit als MMO, ja, das ist richtig nice.
Da würde ich da als Keks rumlaufen oder so.
Megapock, gibt es das als Teams?
Gibt es das als Teams?
Zoom und Teams war gestern, nee, wir brauchen das als Team, Integrations.
Das finde ich nice, das finde ich cool, das hätte ich auch gern.
Ja, mein Chef, der finde das wahrscheinlich auch cool, das ist ja auch ein alter MMO-Spieler,
aber ich glaube, unser Oldschool-Boomer-Unternehmen finde das nicht cool.
Emmerkorn, danke für den Zapp, ja, Boomerbang, ist so.
Wir nutzen da eben so eine ganz coole Lösung, das ist wie so ein kleines Wirt-Ellis-Budow.
Ich finde das nice, das will ich auch haben.
Das ist wie so ein altes Gameboy- oder Nintendo-Spiel.
Jeder in meinem Team hat so einen kleinen Charakter und wir haben hier Meeting-Räume und jeder
der mit seinem Charakter in diesem Raum steht, ist automatisch in einem Video-Meeting.
Hey, Leute, guten Morgen, wie geht es euch?
Das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Java, na gut, es muss Lock4J sein oder Lock4Shell oder wie man es jetzt genau nennen will, weil
von wann ist das Video?
März, ja, ja, das ist Lock4J.
Was war das von?
Können Sie das wiederholen?
Also die haben das davor aufgenommen, als es gerade Lock4J war, garantiert.
Das ist halt wieder das Problem, warum muss es immer Java sein?
Zu klauen.
Ich frage mich einfach um das Volumen des Verkehrs und die Geräusche.
Ich denke, es kommt so viel Verkehr rein.
Warum müssen die so nah an sein Gesicht ran zoomen, man?
Können die nicht einfach den von der Seite irgendwie filmen oder von weiter weg?
Muss ich denn wirklich alles sehen?
Weil wir nicht mehr die Source-IP haben.
Ja, so zum Beispiel.
Für mich ging es los mit einer unschuldigen Nachricht eines Kollegen bei Slack, der halt
beschrieben hat, hey, es wurde gerade diese Lücke in einer Java-Bibliothek veröffentlicht.
Es gibt da so ein Bewertungssystem, das geht von 1 bis 10.
In diesem System hatte die Lücke eine Bewertung von 10.
Ja, Lock4J war so eigentlich das Schlimmste, was du haben konntest.
Das Schlimmste, was es gibt.
Ja, genau, da der Recht.
Und hatte mich eigentlich auf ein schönes Familienwochenende gefreut und ja, letztendlich
saß ich dann.
Ja, bei 2000 Mitarbeitern kann es ja auch nicht angehen, dass man vielleicht eine Vertretung
hat.
Zu Hause auf der Couch mit meinem Laptop.
Das geht ja nicht.
Das ist nicht agile genug, Vertretung zu haben, wo können wir da hin?
Und es schafft in großem Stil, diese Daten irgendwo hinzuschieben.
Die Schwachstelle wurde in einer Software-Komponente entdeckt, d.h. wir mussten erstmal herausfinden,
nutzen wir diese Software-Komponente auch.
Dann haben wir angefangen, unsere ganzen Quellcode zu durchforsten, unsere Infrastruktur zu durchforsten
und haben dann glücklicherweise feststellen können, dass es bei uns nicht im Einsatz
ist.
Kein Lock4J, das ist nicht schlecht Java zu verwenden und nicht vor Lock4J betroffen gewesen
zu sein.
Vielleicht, vielleicht ist auch ihre Version so alt gewesen, dass sie nicht davon betroffen
waren oder so.
Ne, keine Ahnung, also ist nicht sogar so, dass Spring Boot defaultmäßig Lock4J hat
oder sowas?
Ach keine Ahnung, ich kenne mich im Java-Ökosystem null aus.
Also wenn ich was von Java erzähle, könnt ihr immer davon ausgehen, dass es eigentlich
nicht stimmt.
Don't cry so much, da hat er wahrscheinlich sogar recht.
Er sagt hier, ich gucke manchmal einen Java-Entwickler auf Twitch und er erzählt immer, dass Java
halt wegen dem ganzen Tooling drumherum das beste für Enterprise-Sachen ist.
Ja, das kann ich mir, das lasse ich mir gefallen, vor allem, ich glaube der große Pluspunkt
von Java, wie das die coolen Leute natürlich sagen, ist, dass es eben so viele Leute gibt,
die sich damit auskennen.
Und ja, es gibt bestimmt auch sehr viele Tools und Dinger, wobei mich halt interessieren
würde, was es denn für Super Enterprise-Tools gibt, die du bei anderen Sachen halt so konkurrenzlos
nur bei Java hast oder bei anderen Sachen nicht.
Aber allein schon, dass du so viele Leute findest im Java-Umfeld, ist natürlich ein
riesen Bonus.
Ja, ja schauen wir mal weiter.
Würde die Zukunft gewappnet sein?
Ja gut, das würde ja bedeuten, man hat keine Dependencies mehr.
Man hat es jetzt gesehen, mit der letzten Spring-Boot-Lücke vor ein paar Tagen, du kannst im Prinzip
eigentlich nicht so wirklich gewappnet sein dagegen.
Ich meine, was kannst du machen?
Du kannst versuchen, deine Dependencies irgendwie zu reduzieren auf große, bekannte Projekte.
Aber Log4j ist ein großes, bekanntes Projekt, Spring-Boot ist auch ein großes, bekanntes
Projekt, OpenSSL ist auch ein großes, bekanntes Projekt.
Ich meine, du fährst damit vielleicht besser, aber du hast damit auch ab und zu mal irgendwelche
Probleme.
Und einfach sagen, wir nehmen gar keine Dependencies, geht ja auch nicht, da müsstest du ja alles
selbst programmieren.
Und gerade was Kryptographie angeht, das willst du garantiert nicht selbst programmieren.
Also du hast gar keine Möglichkeiten in der Richtung, was dagegen zu machen.
Und wenn du sogar in der blöden Lage bist, Node.js-Anwendungen zu entwickeln, dann ist
ja ganz normal, dass wenn du NPM-Install machst, erst mal 5000 Abhängigkeiten, also
wieder erst mal das komplette Internet nachgeladen.
Genau, und bei großen Bekannten hast du wenigstens die Chance, dass es Patches gibt.
So, was du machen kannst ist, was du machen kannst, Date-Time-Libraries entwickeln jetzt
auch sowas, was du machen kannst ist natürlich, du kannst so allgemeine Dinge machen, du kannst
sinnvolle Firewall-Regeln machen, du kannst sowas wie SE Linux verwenden, du kannst möglichst
viel verkontinuerisiert VMt mit Berechtigungen haben, du kannst da drumherum was bauen natürlich.
Das sorgt dann dafür, dass du zwar immer noch angreifbar bist, aber sich das halt bei
dir vielleicht nicht ausnutzen lässt.
Wenn dann aber sowas wie Log4j kommt, was im Prinzip den fast den normalen Datenweg
irgendwie nimmt, da kannst du nicht viel dagegen machen.
Das Heimtückische bei Log4j war ja, dass du nicht den Service irgendwie angreifen musstest
in dem Sinn, du musstest den Request stellen und hoffen, der wird gelockt und dann ging
das System selbst quasi raus ins Internet und hat Sachen nachgeladen und es ist oftmals
so, dass Zugriffe von innen nach außen erst mal prinzipiell okay sind, es sei denn man
hat sich ordentliche Proxies und Firewall-Regeln überlegt.
Ja, das sind halt so prinzipielle Sachen, die man machen kann, aber Log4j ist schon
wirklich richtig, richtig beschissen gewesen, was das angeht.
Egal, schauen wir mal weiter.
Dann, thanks a lot everyone, talk to you this afternoon, bye bye guys.
Warum futtern die alle Bananen?
Der letzte hat auch schon ganz nach Bananen gefuttert.
So ein Kill-Switch einbauen, falls wir so Aktivitäten entdecken sollten, können wir
sozusagen sofort das ganze System runterfahren und sicherstellen, dass die da sind.
Kill, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich könnte mal vorschlagen, wie wäre es, wenn wir ein Switch-Bot, das ist jetzt nicht
ernst gemeint Leute, wie wäre es denn, das müsste ich auf der Arbeit mal vorschlagen,
wir installieren einen Switch-Bot am zentralen Ausschalter unserer USB-Anlage und wenn dann
einer in die Switch-Bot-App geht und sagt Kill-Switch, dann drückt er da drauf und
dann drückt der Kill-Switch den Knopf von der zentralen USB und alles geht aus.
Das wäre doch mal was, oder alternativ, alternativ was auch gehen würde, ist Switch-Bot am Feuermelder
im Rechenzentrum.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, das könnte man auch machen, nee das würde ich natürlich
nicht machen, aber die Möglichkeit möglichst schnell alles ausschalten zu können ist tatsächlich
sinnvoll.
Manchmal, musst du einfach abwägen, ist Downtime weniger schädlich als Daten geklaut.
Stell euch mal vor, ihr bekommt irgendwie mit, keine Ahnung, ihr habt vielleicht ein Team,
was sich um das Monitoring der Server kümmert und ihr stellt fest, hey von unseren Datenbanken
gibt es auf einmal anstatt 50 MB die Sekunde, gibt es auf einmal 500 MB die Sekunde Traffic
und zwar nicht intern, sondern ins Internet raus, was macht ihr dann?
Also ich glaube in so einem Moment, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat auszuschalten, ist Ausschalten
gar nicht so schlecht.
Du hast zwar Downtime und Gewinnverlust und alles mögliche, Geldverlust durch Downtime,
aber wenn dein Datenbankdump erstmal irgendwo im Tag herumschwirrt, ist vielleicht noch
schlechter.
Betai Golds Ja ist bei uns ähnlich.
Das Wichtigste, was ich aus dem Studium...
Ok, das muss mir jetzt mal einer erklären, warum filmen die seinen Hintern?
But why?
Warum wird da Bobbers gefilmt?
Das Wichtigste, was ich aus dem Studium mitgenommen habe, ist einfach diese Arbeitsweise, dass
man selber Probleme löst, ohne dass man so eine genaue Anleitung braucht, also man kriegt
einfach ein Problem vorgesetzt und kommt dann selber zu einer Lösung.
Problem vorgesetzt in der Position bedeutet wahrscheinlich, kannst du mal gucken, das
geht nicht.
Was geht nicht?
Ja, das alles geht nicht und dann musst du erst mal gucken, ok, was genau will der eigentlich?
Also wenn ich solche Leute im Team habe, das sind die besten Leute.
Jetzt habe ich noch kurz ein Interview, also wir wachsen stark, das ist natürlich extrem
wichtig, neue Mitarbeiter mit an Bord zu bekommen.
Hat er überhaupt, jetzt mal realistisch gefragt, hat er überhaupt Zeit für organisatorische
und Teamleiteraufgaben?
Ich meine, er ist doch mehr oder weniger den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigt, wirklich hands
on Technik zu machen.
Ich meine, und jetzt mal ernsthaft, bei einem 2000 Euro Unternehmen sollte es doch durchaus
möglich sein, da einen Teamleiter zu haben, der sich auch um organisatorische Sachen kümmern
kann.
Ich meine, keine Ahnung, wie es wirklich ist, aber 2000 Mitarbeiter, nicht 2000 Euro, 2000
Mitarbeiter.
Hi Michael, schön dich kennenzulernen, ich würde mich erst mal kurz vorstellen.
Das kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an, wo man ist.
Also, es macht riesig viel aus, ob man jetzt in Frankfurt oder München oder so ist oder
in Bux de Hude, wobei Bux de Hude ja mittlerweile deutlich bekannter ist als früher.
Ja, ziemlich gut, vielversprechender Kandidat, also kann weitergehen.
Der obligatorische Kicker, da darf nicht fehlen, weil wir sind ja ein Start-up.
Klassische Nerds, auch im Team, die sich gern mit der Thematik noch weiter beschäftigen.
Das ist oft so ein Klischee eigentlich, dass ein Informatiker jemand ist, der immer nur
am Computer hängt, der irgendwie keinen Sport macht, immer nur Pizza.
Warum?
Und Marte trinkt, privat interessiert mich schon für Technologie, aber ich bin jetzt
keiner, der irgendwie Home-Automation und sowas hat, das sehe ich ganz entspannt.
So ein bisschen Technik hat man dann doch überall, das ist auch mein einziges Stück
Smartphone.
Also die Maschine geht immer in der Früh schon an, weil die es so lang vorheizen muss.
Genau, und dann stehe ich auf und kann direkt mit dem ersten Kaffee loslegen.
Moment, what the fuck, hier kann man doch nicht arbeiten.
Ach nee, der arbeitet nicht, der sitzt am Handy, okay, verstehe.
Wir gucken uns gleich mal Ceylonis an, aber mit so einem Stuhl kann ich nicht arbeiten.
Leute, ich muss jetzt mal eine Sache klarstellen, auch wenn ich zu solchen Videos jetzt ab und
zu mal ein bisschen über die Stränge schlage oder so, ich habe nichts gegen die Leute,
die in diesen Videos gezeigt werden und ich gehe davon aus, dass das, wenn überhaupt,
am Beitrag liegt, dass da manche Sachen nicht so rauskommen, nicht, dass die Leute wirklich
planlos sind.
Ich habe vor dem Studium keine einzige Zeile Code geschrieben, ich habe mich relativ spontan
dazu entschieden, Informatik zu studieren, hauptsächlich, weil ich nach München…
Aber was er jetzt wirklich macht, ist jetzt nicht rausgekommen, oder?
Ich meine, der Titel ist, ich wehre Hacker-Angriffe ab, ja was macht er denn eigentlich jetzt?
Ich meine, das Einzige, was wir gesehen haben, ist, sie waren in einem Meeting zu Log4j,
wahrscheinlich, vermute ich mal, und haben irgendwas von Source-IP erzählt.
Das ist es aber nicht wirklich, oder?
Klar, die ersten Semester, da hing ich sicher an manche anderen ein bisschen hinterher,
aber da kommen wir dann schon ganz gut rein.
Ab dem, glaube ich, vierten Semester hat man dann mehr Seminare und Praktika und da habe
ich dann so, ja, glaube ich, nochmal richtig die Leidenschaft gefunden.
Der Hackathon war, glaube ich, 2015, da habe ich noch studiert.
Ich habe dann meinen Vertrag schon Anfang oder Mitte 2016 unterschrieben, noch während
meiner Masterarbeit.
Okay, okay, es geht noch weiter, jetzt wird kill-switched.
Also meine Idee mit dem Switch-Bot an der USB steht noch.
Leute, wisst ihr, was der beste Kill-Switch ist?
Es ist gut zu wissen, stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt eine Kiste, die sich nicht mehr runterfahren
lässt und ihr habt keinen Zugriff auf das Management-Interface, das kommt ja durchaus
vor, dass Kisten so sehr hängen, dass sie sich nicht mehr ausschalten lassen.
Es gibt eine Sache, wo ihr jede Linux-Kiste sicher ausschalten könnt und zwar das hier,
guckt mal, fass mal auf, ihr macht einfach, müsst ja alles gut machen, anders funktioniert
das nicht, ihr sagt Echo-O nach, warte mal, ist das O, das ist O und was war B noch mal,
B ist Reboot oder Reboot-System, also ihr könnt, ihr könnt immediately Reboot oder
immediately Shutdown machen, also wenn ihr sagen wollt, ihr wollt ausschalten, ist noch
nie passiert, doch, doch, kommt öfters mal vor, ihr sagt, ihr sagt Echo-O und dann Rock-Sys-LQ-Trigger
und es passt mal auf, was passiert, wenn ich das jetzt ausführe, bam, aus, einfach aus,
nicht Init-0, Init-0 run Stop-Skripte und alles, Reboot geht auch nicht, das hier schaltet
wirklich ATX-mäßig das System aus, das ist quasi ähnlich zu, ich halte den Power-Schalter
gedrückt, es ist einfach aus, ohne Festplatten zu sünken, ohne Stop-Skripte, ohne alles,
also sprich, wenn jetzt da grad was läuft, was viel IO auf der Festplatte macht, kann
es sein, dass die, das ist quasi, das ist quasi Stecker ziehen, es kann es auch sein,
dass er erstmal ein File-System check macht zum Starten, ne, macht er nicht, also das
ist immer noch der beste, der beste Kill-Switch, wenn man noch an die Systeme per SSH drankommt.
Wie war der Befehl, der eine Null-Pointer-D-Reference macht, hier Colonel-Panic, dass irgendeiner
Colonel-Panic auslöst, ach, das, das gibt's, hier, hier, C, C ist das, können wir auch
mal ausprobieren, Leute, machen wir mal, ja ja, meine History ist korrupt, ich weiß,
dass meine History korrupt ist, weil, weil ich einfach ausgeschaltet hab, guck mal,
also es ist auch nix, es ist auch nix in der, in der History drinne, Echo, äh, was war das,
C, Rock, Sys, RQ, also wer schon immer mal einen Linux-Crash sehen wollte, so sieht's
aus, achso, nein, er ist einfach gecrashed, die VM ist einfach, einfach disabled, es geht
nix mehr, einfach abgekackt, okay, dachte man sieht wenigstens noch einen Colonel-Panic
oder sowas, naja, gut, weiter, weiter im Text, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, Kill-Switch,
Moment, was will er scale, Sekunde,
es ist quasi die Nuke, da ist die Moab, Mods, Mods, Mods, Mod-Check, Mod-Check, nice,
nice, man ist natürlich dazu, warum reden die eigentlich Englisch, wenn die alle Deutsch
sind, was kann man machen für den krassen International Vibe oder so, einfach alles
sofort abzuschalten, aber das macht es auch extrem schwierig, dann noch herauszufinden,
was ist eigentlich passiert, wobei man muss halt sagen, in der Regel schaltest du ja nicht
alles ab, in der Regel würdest du quasi Server ausschalten, aber Netzwerkgeräte bleiben
noch da und sowas, also da hat er recht, da braucht man eine sinnvolle Strategie für,
es ist wahrscheinlich besser, sich im Vorfeld das zu überlegen, als dann wirklich mal irgendwann
den Stecker zu ziehen, zu versuchen, irgendwie die Tür zu schließen und dann kann man nämlich
viel besser im Nachhinein noch analysieren, was ist eigentlich schiefgegangen, ja, Eingang
zu machen ist natürlich immer sinnvoll, wir haben einfach jetzt ein paar Ideen, sind wir
durchgegangen, wie man mehr oder weniger mit einem Schlag, also die beste Variante wäre
natürlich das Kabel zum Internetprovider zu ziehen, das stimmt wohl, auf der anderen
Seite, wenn du irgendwelche Remoteshells, Backdoor, sonst was infizierte Arbeitsplatzrechner
hast, dann wird es dadurch ja nicht besser. Ne, Ports schließen alleine bringt dir nix,
geht ja hauptsächlich jetzt auch um ausgehenden Traffic. Du willst wahrscheinlich den Switch
Port zum Provider runterfahren, wenn schon. Kompletten Netzwerk Traffic aus unserer Infrastruktur
heraus unterbinden könnte, da hat sich dann eine Idee als die vielversprechendste heraus
kristallisiert und genau dafür erstelle ich jetzt ein Ticket für das Team, da wird dann
die nächsten Tage jemand anfangen, daran zu arbeiten. Hauptsache Ticket erstellt, Aspar.
Ich wollte noch ein kleines Update zum Killswitch Projekt liefern, wir haben es jetzt diese
Woche noch ausprobiert, es hat super funktioniert, also nachdem wir den Killswitch aktivieren,
fließen keine Daten mehr aus dem System raus, Mission erfolgreich und wir können den zukünftigen
Sicherheitslücken wesentlich entspannter entgegenschauen. Danke, tschau tschau.
Das war's von mir und meinem Job, wenn ihr noch mehr über das Informatikstudium lernen
wollt, dann klickt hier und wenn ihr wissen wollt, wieviel ein Informatiker so verdient,
dann klickt hier. Das haben wir auch schon geguckt.
Haben die den Killswitch wirklich getestet? Realistisch betrachtet glaube ich nicht. Nee,
das war kein Video, wieviel es geht. Wahrscheinlich haben die den Killswitch nicht getestet, ich
gehe mal davon aus, dass die gesagt haben, managment technisch, so nach dem Motto, ja
glaubt ihr denn es funktioniert und die haben gesagt ja oder haben die gesagt es reicht
uns. Wahrscheinlich haben die es nie wirklich getestet. Gibt es bei uns auch so ein paar
Dinge, die wir haben rein zur Beruhigung, aber die noch nie jemand ausprobiert hat.
Einen Killswitch am Eingang zum Provider kannst du schlecht in FVM testen.
Homelab 2021, also Videos gucke ich auch immer gerne.
Zeig her. Homelab 2021.
Warum sind das bloß 3D Render und nix in echt? Warum testet man das nicht? Ganz einfach,
weil es Geld kostet, wenn die Systeme nicht erreichbar sind.
Vielleicht haben sie es irgendwann nachts um drei oder so getestet.
Das könnte sein. Aber allgemein sind solche Tests immer sehr
unbeliebt, weil sobald das System nicht da ist, ist es halt immer so, dass es in der
Regel Geld kostet. Oder was halt Geld kostet. In der Zeit bringt
es kein Geld. So rum. Du kannst den Port runterfahren bei Cisco
Routern relativ einfach. Ich bin mir aber aus dem Kopf nicht mal
sicher wie das geht. No Shutdown ist das.
Warte mal. No Shutdown ist Port hochfahren bei Cisco, oder? Das war doch so die Logik.
No Shutdown ist Port hochfahren und Shutdown ist Port runterfahren.
Das ist ja die Cisco Logik, dass du immer No da vorschreibst und es ist das Gegenteil.
No Shut. Genau.
Karamell Barbecue Nr. 1 Schokobrunn weiß Bescheid.
No Shutdown. Genau. Homelab. Ja, kommt da noch was.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Er hat 3D Ränder von seinem angeblichen
Homelab anstatt es zu zeigen. Lull. Was ist das für Chebathe Fake Shit?
Alter. Was ist das für ein Kack?
Komplett useless Video. Gut, gut das.
Jetzt habe ich zugemacht. Was wollte ich sagen?
Gut, dass es keine Dislikes mehr gibt, wo man das richtig erkennen kann,
wie kacke das ist. Chebathe.
Ja, das Arduino Pro Ding ist ziemlich unsinnig.
Hier ist eine Motte rumgeflogen. Boah.
Huge Reactions Leute. Ich habe gerade die Motte, die an mir
vorbeigeflogen ist, mit der Hand gefangen.
Aber sie lebt noch und fliegt jetzt irgendwo rum hier wieder.
Massive Reactions. 360 No Scope.
Jetzt habe ich ganz vergessen, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Avira installieren einfach. Ja, Windows Defender überall.
Der Arduino Pro bringt nichts, weil das kein Arduino im eigentlichen
Sinne ist, sondern das ist ein ganz normales Linux Raspberry Pi
Konkurrent. Es hat nichts mit den Standard Arduino
Controllern zu tun, also irgendwie ziemlich unsinnig.
Der Witz ist bei uns jetzt mal jetzt mal so wie das Schwank.
Nee, Story ist Story aus dem echten Leben.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es so. Sie haben nicht.
Sie haben nicht Avira Free Antivirus installiert.
Sie haben und das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Sie haben auf allen Systemen Windows Defender installiert.
Sogar auf Linux. Wir haben wirklich auf allen
unsere Linux Server Windows Defender.
Auf Linux, wir haben Windows Defender.
Okay, es heißt nicht Windows Defender.
Es heißt Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection.
Es gibt Windows Defender auf Linux.
Microsoft Defender Advanced Threat Protection nennt sich das.
Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection.
Ja, und wir haben jetzt Windows Defender auf jeder
Linux Kiste und das Ding macht nur Probleme.
Wirklich nur, ausschließlich nur Probleme.
Das ist die größte Bullshit Software überhaupt.
Das Ding hat noch nicht eine Sache gebracht.
Gut, das ist immer schwer zu sagen.
Mit hat was gebracht oder nicht.
In der Regel hoffst du ja, dass du es nie brauchst.
Und wenn du es brauchst, bist du froh, dass du es hast.
Aber bis jetzt hat es noch nicht eins gebracht.
Und es macht immer Probleme.
Das Ding hat seit letzter Version hat es ein Ultramemory Leak.
Und das ist so krass, das Memory Leak, dass unser Support
auf manchen Systemen den Windows Defender nächtlich restarten muss,
dass der RAM Verbrauch nicht den Server abkacken lässt.
Das ist kein Spaß, Leute.
Das ist Real Life.
Ach ja, und der Windows Defender liegt manchmal Passwörter im Log.
Mich hat mal ein Kollege angeschrieben und sagte zu mir,
Max, sag mal, ist das dein Passwort?
Man meinte, ja, das ist mein Passwort.
Und da hat er mir das Log vom Windows Defender gezeigt.
Und der Windows Defender hat irgendwelche Sachen gelockt
auf Linux Server mit meinem Passwort im Klartext drin.
Ach so, so viel zu super Security Software, ja.
Klingt nach Altifutsch Krankenhaus.
Nein, ich arbeite nicht im Krankenhaus.
Ich arbeite bei einem der größten Finanzdienstleister,
die es in Deutschland gibt.
Also wir sind so Oldschool Business Stonks, das gibt es gar nicht.
Heute bestes Wetter, da hat man gar keine Ausrede, drin zu bleiben.
Doch, zwingt dich keiner, rauszugehen.
Das reicht doch als Ausrede.
Aber ich war gestern schon draußen.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Ich war gestern gestern echt an der frischen Luft hier im Wald.
Ja, gibt es.
Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Was ist das?
Auch irgendein Antivirus-Shit?
Autonome KIN-Punkten-Sicherheitsplattform.
Boah, der Titel ist mir erscheint schon zu Big Stonks.
Zu Passwort-lastig.
Nichts ist so Oldschool wie im Krankenhaus.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ganz ehrlich, das letzte, wo ich sein möchte, ist im Krankenhaus.
Wusstet ihr, dass die meisten Leute im Krankenhaus sterben?
Gut, ist ja auch logisch.
Die Leute sind auch krank, wenn sie ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Ich sag doch nur.
Ja, ist eigentlich logisch, dass es so ist.
Das ist wie die meisten Unfälle passieren im Haushalt.
Wollte nur mal Danke sagen an Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker.
Nice, das ist schön, das freut mich zu hören.
Wann geht's los?
Erster Achter?
Oder erst für nächstes Jahr?
Guck mal, ich suche nicht nach random Dinger.
Ach so, das kann ich suchen.
Cloudstrike.
Führen in Cloud-basiertem Endgeräteschutz.
Okay, es geht schon gut los.
Wo steht das?
Moment, Moment.
Einzige als führend bezeichnete Lösung in beiden.
What the fuck, nur weil irgendwo steht, dass es führend ist.
Cloudstrike ist die erste Cloud-Native Endgeräteschutz-Plattform, die KI-Analyse und Expo...
Alles klar, da kann ja nichts mehr passieren.
Also ich kenne die nicht, die scheinen relativ groß zu sein.
Aber wenn ich sowas schon lese...
Cloud-Native mit KI.
Alles klar, da fehlt bloß noch Blockchain eigentlich.
Was hast du für Aufgang in deinem Job? Musst du mal bei mir auf YouTube gucken, da habe ich schon zig Videos zugemacht.
Ich lache wegen den ganzen Buzzwords.
Wie findest du eigentlich die neue Ordnung für Fachinformatiker?
Ja, ich habe damit relativ wenig Berührungspunkte.
Inwieweit sich das durchsetzen wird, muss ich zeigen.
Es gibt ja zwei neue Fachinformatiker-Richtungen.
Das eine war...
Ich kriege das gar nicht mal zusammen.
Vernetzte Systeme oder sowas war das eine.
Das andere war Datenanalyse oder so.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mal aus dem Kopf.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ob es wirklich was bringt, bin ich überfragt.
Ich wollte auch mal fragen, welche Programmiersprache man lernen sollte für Fachinformatiker-Anwendungsentwicklung.
Du kommst darauf an, was in deinem Unternehmen angesagt ist bzw. was dich interessiert.
Pauschal.
Wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast, was du machen sollst, dann nimm einen Browser und einen Texteditor und fang mit JavaScript, HTML und CSS an.
Erstens, frontend braucht jeder, immer, irgendwann mal.
Und du brauchst nichts Großartiges für außer einen Browser und einen Texteditor.
Und du siehst, was passiert.
Mit JavaScript kommst du im Prinzip auch ein bisschen auf den Backend zurecht.
JavaScript können kommt man eigentlich nicht dran vorbei.
Deswegen finde ich das zum Einstieg nicht schlecht.
Wenn du natürlich schon spezielle Vorstellungen hast, was du machen willst, dann kann man da auch vielleicht was anderes empfehlen.
Ruby.
Webseitenstells, genau.
Es muss aber mit JavaScript, muss ja nicht Webseitenstells sein.
Wenn ihr Python lernt, ist doch schon mal was.
Damit kann man auch was anfangen.
Hab eine Frage an alle.
Kennt ihr doch sicher die Methode per CMD, die das Windows-Passwort changen?
Nö.
Kenne ich nicht.
Ich hab von Windows keine Ahnung.
Ja, besser als die Schulen, die anfangen C++ zu machen und sowas.
Als würden die Lehrer das verstehen.
Niemand auf der Welt versteht C++, nicht mal der Erfinder.
Ja, macht durchaus Sinn.
Python ist eine super Einsteiger-Programmiersprache.
Ich persönlich bin der Meinung, dass JavaScript sinnvoller ist.
Allein schon, weil du mehr damit machen kannst, umfangreichere Sachen damit machen kannst,
sowohl Frontend als auch Backendsachen.
Du nichts als Voraussetzungen brauchst und im Endeffekt, es einfach geht in jedem x-beliebigen
Browser und du was siehst, was du machst.
Aber Python ist auch wunderbar zum Einsteigen.
Python ist definitiv die schönere Sprache im Vergleich zu JavaScript.
Ja, der Name sagt mir irgendwas.
Geht, wir machen das immer noch Leute, ja.
Bootstrap und JavaScript haben erstmal nichts miteinander zu tun.
Bootstrap ist ein CSS-Helper-Framework mit ein bisschen JavaScript.
Aber mit Bootstrap alleine baust du keine Web-Anwendung.
Und mit Bootstrap baust du auch keine Node.js-Backend-Anwendung.
Du kommst an JavaScript nicht vorbei.
Gerade wenn du Frontend-Sachen machen willst, kommst du, egal was du machst, du kommst nicht an JavaScript vorbei.
Es gibt nichts anderes als JavaScript im Frontend.
Jetzt kommen die nächsten und sagen, Max, aber WebAssembly.
Nein, aber selbst den WebAssembly nicht.
Ein WebAssembly-Dom-Interaktion auch nicht gescheit funktioniert ohne JavaScript.
Außerdem, wer bitte schön macht WebAssembly von Hand, da kompilierst du hin.
TypeScript, ja, TypeScript ist JavaScript.
Nö, WebAssembly ist kein echtes Assembler-Zeug.
WebAssembly ist ein Compile-Target, was im Browser läuft.
Wo du in Browser lauffähige Sachen kompilieren kannst aus allen anderen Programmiersprachen.
Aber für Dom-Interaktionen und sowas brauchst du, glaube ich, immer noch JavaScript.
Coboll lernen, da ist tatsächlich was dran.
Coboll-Leute sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen immer noch gefragt.
Das liegt aber daran, weil Coboll-Scheiß mal nicht mehr los wird.
Wir haben einmal vor drei Jahren oder vor zwei Jahren zum Weihnachtstream, Sekunde.
Archiv, wo bloß.
Coboll.
Wir haben am 25. Dezember 2020 einen Stream gemacht, wo wir Coboll programmiert haben.
Und ich sag euch, Leute, das war...
Guckt mal, da war mein Desktop noch ein bisschen freier.
Das war Hardcore-Paints-Champion.
Guckt euch das mal an. Ich hab auch die passende Schriftart gemacht in meinem Editor.
Also, man braucht schon Comic Sans, dass man das ordentlich programmieren kann.
Guckt euch dieses Elend mal an.
Weil ich nur die Hi-IQ-Leute im Stream haben will, Max.
Fortran-Stream. Hört mal auf.
Perform Until EOF. Das war so schrecklich. Das war so schrecklich. Ich kann mich doch dran erinnern.
Guckt euch den Scheiß an.
Multi-Threaded in Coboll. Ja, das ist auch gut.
Boah, ich will gar nicht mehr dran erinnert werden.
Nein, da sag ich jetzt nichts zu, weil es G-Bait-Frage ist.
Stimmt, mittlerweile gibt es ja sogar Projekte, dass WebAssembly serverseitig läuft.
Nee. Es gibt bei vielen Banken noch Überbleibsel, gerade im Mainframe-Bereich Coboll.
Das sind so fette IBM-Kisten, die du kaufen musst für viel Geld, die dir dann trotzdem nicht richtig gehören.
Herr N-Punkt ist Mainframe-Experte. Ich hab mal ein Video gemacht.
Herr N-Punkt spricht Klartext. Der Niklas ist Mainframe-Experte.
Der kennt sich mit Coboll und Mainframes aus.
Mein ehemaliger Azubi von mir. Mit dem hab ich hier ein Video aufgenommen.
Und der macht Mainframe-Coboll-Gedöns.
Wobei das Coboll-Programmieren, hat er gesagt, wurde zu irgendwelchen Indern outsourced.
Das wird natürlich super funktionieren.
Das ist RGB-Beleuchtung auch. Ist Go sinnvoll zu lernen?
Ja, auch Go ist eine ganz gute Einsteiger-Programmiersprache, wobei ich persönlich Go umständlicher als es sein müsste finde.
Aber angeblich hat Go jetzt auch Generics seit der aktuellen Version.
Das müsste man sich eigentlich mal wieder angucken, Leute.
Für lange nichts mehr in Go gemacht.
Was würdest du mir für eine Technologie empfehlen? Ich hab eine Axis.
Nein, Gott! Nein, Gott, bitte nein! Nein! Nein! Nein!
Naja, ich sag mal so.
Wenn du was hast, was funktioniert. Egal wie lächerlich das mit Axis ist.
Also wenn es geht. Man muss das Rad nicht neu erfinden.
Auch wenn ich Axis immer äußerst painstampig finde.
Und es gibt garantiert ordentliche und bestimmt auch günstige oder wenn nicht sogar kostenlose Vereins-Management-Lösungen.
Also ich denke, du musst da gar nichts selbst programmieren.
Ich kenne dazu nichts, weil ich mich damit noch nie beschäftigt habe.
Aber es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass es da nicht schon fertige Lösungen für gibt.
Ich meine Vereins-Management bzw. Mitglieder-Datenbanken, das ist ja wohl eines der oldschooligsten Sachen, die es gibt.
Da gibt es garantiert ordentliche Software und höchstwahrscheinlich sogar kostenlos für.
Wie der nur das machen kann. Ich würde da gar nichts selbst für entwickeln.
Cobol Auffrischungskurs, ne ne ne. Genug Cobol.
Ja, ich habe es auch jetzt noch nicht erlebt, dass das gut funktioniert hat mit programmieren outsourcen nach Indien.
Aber gut, wahrscheinlich muss die Erfahrung jeder mal selbst machen.
Wusstest du, dass jemand einen Weg gefunden hat, um CSL als Backendsprache zu nutzen?
Wundert mich nicht.
Ich meine, es gibt auch Whitespace als Programmiersprache.
Hast du Lost sein Video schon gesehen? Was hat er denn für ein Video gemacht?
YouTube, Losts.
Nächster Battlefielder, ne, aber da weiß ich, um was es geht.
Dazu wollte ich eventuell auch was machen, aber es ist jetzt eigentlich schon zu spät.
Ja, ich habe Switch-Spots, habe ich, habe ich.
Ach im Einsatz, ne, ich habe welche, aber ich habe aktuell keinen mehr im Einsatz.
Über Homebridge, ich hätte geguckt, ob es irgendeine Home Assistant Integration gibt.
C ist gut, C++ ist Scheiße.
Gegen C habe ich gar nichts, C ist Pog.
Aber C++ ist Müll.
Ok, ich habe es geschafft. Nice.
Ok, was schauen wir uns jetzt an?
C Sharp ist Pog.
Waren die beiden ja auch so träge?
Du meinst, dass die verzögert geschaltet haben? Ja.
Die waren nicht die allerschnellsten Verzögerungen von, ich würde mal sagen.
Oder was weiß ich, 3-4 Sekunden hatten die schon teilweise.
Deswegen, die Switch-Spots sind eine super Idee, die Ausführung ist...
Ja, weiß nicht.
Niu-Shali, ne, Niu-Shai.
QQ, danke für den Sub.
So, was schauen wir uns als nächstes an?
Hat Level Cap jetzt ein aktuelles Video?
This Week in Gaming? Nope.
Schauen wir uns nicht an, schauen wir uns...
Wie oft habe ich YouTube Start-Seite denn?
Ach, das war das Jebait-Video.
Making Lego Cars climb walls.
Ok, auf geht's.
Eine Runde Lego-Video, weil es geht.
Geht nur 8 Minuten.
Oh nein, das funktioniert nicht. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Das so wird das nix.
Oh, RIP.
Try and add a new level.
Ok, ok, ok.
Ok, ok, ok, ok.
Try and error.
Ist das hier.
Er hat erstmal ein paar UML-Diagramme machen für seine Lego-Konstruktion.
Und eine Sprintplanung.
Sonst kann das nicht funktionieren.
Oh, oh.
Das fällt doch um, oder?
Nein, nein, nein.
Es hat funktioniert.
Es sah nicht elegant aus, aber es hat funktioniert.
Oh.
Bam.
Es sieht immer weniger elegant aus, aber wahrscheinlich funktioniert es jetzt.
Jetzt hat er ein bisschen vorgespult.
Und, und, und.
Aha, da hängts. Ok.
Wisst ihr was Massive-Five-Hat gewesen wäre an der Stelle?
Guckt mal.
Was jetzt?
Wo war er denn?
Wo war er denn gerade?
Wisst ihr was Massive-Five-Hat wäre, wenn das nicht geht?
Der müsste mit so einem Lego-Neumatik-Ding vorne was haben, was er ausklappen kann.
Wir waren Level 3.
Guckt mal, wenn es jetzt hängt, jetzt bräuchte er was hier oben, was er ausklappen kann nach vorne.
Und dann wird es quasi mehr nach vorne ziehen und dann wird es runterklappen.
Massive-Hebelgesetz, genau.
Bam.
Das Ding sieht jetzt halt absolut nicht mehr elegant aus.
Das sieht ziemlich, soll ich sagen, ziemlich pepega aus das Auto mittlerweile.
Das würde dann auch zuerst aufschlagen, das ist richtig, aber das ist ja egal, das geht ums Rüberkommen, nicht ums Heile drüberkommen.
Übrigens, weil im Chat gerade diskutiert wird wegen Verschlüsselung und sonst was, eine gute Verschlüsselung,
wenn der Key weg ist, ist die Daten auch weg.
Das muss so sein.
Wenn es eine Recovery-Möglichkeit gibt, ohne den Key, dann ist es scheiß Verschlüsselung.
Oh, jetzt kommen die Five-Hat-Tactics hier.
Boah.
Alter.
Das ist ja immer absolutes Next-Level-Shit.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Richtig, richtig Five-Hat-ig.
Six-Hat.
Es hat funktioniert, es ist drüber gekommen.
Ja, OTP ist das Einzige, was mathematisch gesehen sicher ist, weil du jedes Zeichen mit einem Zeichen in deinem Key verschlüsselst.
Also dein Key ist exakt so lang wie deine Message.
Das ist halt in der Regel nicht sonderlich praktikabel.
Und du darfst auf gar keinen Fall das OTP zweimal verwenden.
Dann hast du richtig Probleme.
Da können die auch nichts machen, Leute.
Da können die auch nichts machen.
Wenn das ordentlich verschlüsselt ist, da kann weder irgendwie die Five-Hat-Forensik noch irgendwelche Zero-Days was machen.
Zero-Days bringen ja prinzipiell nur was, wenn dein System läuft.
Also mal angenommen, du hast jetzt zum Beispiel eine Windows-Kiste mit verschlüsselter Festplatte.
Und du startest die, gibst deinen Passwort ein und du hast dann irgendeine Sicherheitslücke oder irgendeinen Keylogger oder was auch immer was drauf, was dein Passwort abgreift oder was sagt, wir entschlüsseln jetzt die Festplatte oder so.
Dazu muss das System ja erstmal laufen.
Wenn du eine verschlüsselte Festplatte hast, aus dem Rechner ausgebaut und du möchtest darauf zugreifen, hast nicht den Key, da kannst du der krasseste Forensik-Mensch sein und der krasseste Zero-Day-Hackerman.
Du wirst da bei einem ordentlichen Key wohlgemerkt, du wirst da nichts machen, es sei denn du hast Millionen von Jahren Zeit.
Ordentlich verschlüsselte Platte, sei es Veracrypt oder was auch immer, hast du gelitten.
Und wenn die das richtig gemacht haben, dass das ohne den Key nicht aufgeht, da ist Schluss.
Aber ok, ich weiß nicht ob es bei Bitlogger nicht irgendwelche Hintertöne gibt, keine Ahnung.
Wichtig ist ordentliche Verschlüsselung, Key weg, Daten weg.
Sollte das bei Bitlogger nicht so sein, dann ist Bitlogger keine ordentliche Verschlüsselung.
Also sofern man ohne Key irgendwie noch drauf zugreifen kann, ist es keine ordentliche Verschlüsselung.
Wenn man den Key nicht sicher abspeichert, dann ist man selbst dran schuld.
Veracrypt hat auch Backup-Keys, aber der Unterschied zwischen deinem Passwort und den Backup-Keys ist folgender.
Die Festplatte wird nicht mit deinem Passwort verschlüsselt.
Die Festplatte wird mit einem Key verschlüsselt und diesen Key kannst du anlocken mit deinem Passwort.
Das wird aus Performance-Gründen gemacht.
Aber es kommt aufs Gleiche heraus, Passwort weg, Key nicht mehr entschlüsselbar und dementsprechend Festplatte nicht entschlüsselbar.
In Veracrypt ist es so, der Key liegt am Anfang der Festplatte und am Ende der Festplatte nochmal.
Aber du brauchst trotzdem dein Passwort, um den Key zu anlocken.
Wenn du den Key nicht anlocken kannst, dann kannst du mit dem Key logischerweise auch nicht die Platte entschlüsseln.
Und wenn das bei BitLocker nicht so ist, dann ist BitLocker Müll.
Du hast ja auch ein Smartphone, ich überlege mir gerade für meine Steckdosen Schaltaktoren von Shelley zu kaufen.
Ja, die Shelley sind nicht schlecht, kannst du die eigentlich bedenkenlos holen.
Die Shelley sind gut, die sind relativ klein, die passen auch in die Dose, falls du die da haben willst.
Die sind auch standardmäßig firmwertechnisch brauchbar, ohne Flaschen.
Ich habe eine Mischung, ich habe Shelley, allerdings zum größten Teil habe ich Steckdosen, die man quasi, also Zwischenstecker.
Z-Wave und TAS Motor selbst geflasht. Und Steckdosenleisten auch selbst geflasht.
Harter euer Heli, danke für den Zap. Ja, dann ist das komplett sinnlos.
Ja, wenn du das über DMA umgehen kannst, dann ist der Key irgendwo gespeichert im Klartext, wo er nicht sein sollte.
Das ist halt Müll.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob Shelley's DMA haben, ich glaube schon.
Shelley hat doch auch DMA? Doch klar, hat Shelley DMA.
Also wenn du ein ordentliches Passwort hast, und die irgendwas verwenden, was als sicher gilt,
sagst du, ich nehme AIS als Verschlüsselung, und die AIS-Implementierung ist ordentlich, dann machst du manuell nichts.
Was meint ihr denn, warum das auch, was weiß ich, FBI, CIA und drei Buchstaben, setze drei Buchstabenbehörde ein,
auch deutsche Behörden so große Probleme haben, wenn die Leute ihre Festplatten mit Veracrypt oder sonst wie verschlüsselt haben.
Und ein ordentliches Passwort haben, die kommen da nicht dran.
Oder meint ihr, die denken sich das nur aus, die sagen, ja, ja, wir kommen in Wirklichkeit dran, behaupten nur, wir würden nicht drankommen.
Da machst du nichts.
Nehmen wir mal Veracrypt zum Beispiel, da weiß ich, dass das schon öfters mal zu Problemen geführt hat, weil man eben nicht rangekommen ist.
Bei Bitlocker, keine Ahnung, ob es da nicht irgendwelche Hintertüren gibt, du machst nichts.
Du machst nichts, wenn das ein ordentliches Passwort ist, du machst nichts.
Keine Chance.
Die einzige, also Bitlocker, ich habe keine Ahnung von Bitlocker, habe ich nie verwendet, aber Veracrypt, wenn du ein ordentliches Passwort hat,
dann ist es nicht für 95% ein Bevölker, es ist für niemand knackbar, es sei denn, es sei denn, und das muss natürlich immer, muss natürlich immer sein,
es werden Sicherheits-, es werden Schwachstellen in der Implementierung von Veracrypt gefunden.
Das kann natürlich sein, ist aber jetzt zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt nicht sonderlich wahrscheinlich.
Wenn das ordentlich implementiert ist AIS, oder was auch immer, was sie nehmen wahrscheinlich, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es AIS ist, gerade weil das die CPUs auch in Hardware mittlerweile wunderbar können, dann ist vorbei.
Genau, nur wenn das Passwort scheiße ist, dann machst du natürlich nichts. Wenn das Passwort kacke ist, dann ist es halt kacke.
Aber wenn du ein ordentliches Passwort hast, dann ist es vorbei, es sei denn, du hast ein paar Millionen Jahre Zeit.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich blöd. Ja, das ist richtig. Langes Passwort ist wichtiger als komplexes Passwort. Zumindest kann man das so pauschal sagen.
Man wird immer Gegenbeispiele finden mit super einfachen langen Passwörtern, aber in der Regel, nachdem du ja auch nicht wirklich was über den Aufbau des Passworts weißt im Vorfeld normalerweise, ist langes Passwort immer besser als komplexes Passwort.
Jetzt könnte man sagen, langes und komplexes Passwort in Kombination ist noch besser, ja, aber die Länge fließt deutlich mehr in die Zeit ein als die Komplexität.
Ja, genau. Das ist richtig. Correctors battery stable. Das ist gut, ja, das ist ein gutes Passwort.
Ich meine jetzt vielleicht eins zu eins das aus dem Comic zu nehmen, vielleicht eher nicht, aber das ist ein besseres Passwort als das.
Die Leute wiederholen einfach ihr kurzes Passwort. Das ist auch okay, das kann man auch machen.
Natürlich ist es besser, man macht das nicht, aber ein langes Passwort ist prinzipiell immer gut, immer besser, immer besser.
Du weißt ja nicht den Aufbau und außerdem gibt es so extrem viele Möglichkeiten auch an Wörtern. Man muss ja davon ausgehen, du weißt nicht, wie das Passwort aufgebaut ist.
Wüsstest du jetzt, der verwendet nur 500 der meisten verwendeten englischen Wörtern und selbst da sind die Kombinationsmöglichkeiten schon relativ hoch, dann hast du vielleicht bessere Chancen.
Aber trotzdem, langes Passwort ist das Wichtige bei der Geschichte.
Kannst du auch machen, ja. Das Verliet-Speaking wie auch immer Hauptsache wichtig ist, wichtig ist lang, wichtig ist lang.
Weil die Kombination, die Kombination ist ja im Endeffekt Anzahl an möglichen Zeichen hoch Länge.
Und nachdem es hoch Länge ist, ist die Länge quasi für die möglichen Kombinationen deutlich wichtiger als die Komplexität.
Also 26 hoch 20 ist viel viel mehr als 52 hoch 12. Die Länge ist entscheidend, ja.
Passwort Manager ist in dem Fall eine super Geschichte, weil da kannst du dir lange und komplexe Passwörter generieren lassen.
Das einzige Problem bei Passwort Manager ist, es gibt zwei grundsätzliche Probleme, die ich bei Passwort Manager sehe.
Das erste ist Leute, die auf Cloud Passwörter setzen, würde ich prinzipiell nie machen.
Also wer der Meinung ist, quasi das Wichtigste, was er in seinem digitalen Leben hat, nämlich seine Zugangspasswörter zu allen Diensten,
einem Cloud Anbieter anzuvertrauen, der kann noch so viel versprechen von, wir wessen das Passwort selbst nicht, weil es alles kleinzeitig encryptet ist.
Aber allein schon Passwörter in der Cloud bei einem fremden Anbieter zu speichern, das ist das erste Problem.
Das würde ich nie machen. Vertraue nie einem Cloud Anbieter deine Passwörter an, nie. Egal was die erzählen.
Und das nächste Problem ist, wenn man zum Beispiel sowas wie KeyPass verwendet, dass du natürlich trotzdem anfällig bist für Keylogger
oder irgendwelche Programme, die die Passwörter aus dem RAM abgreifen. Zum Beispiel Teile von der KeyPass Datenbank sind,
wenn du das Master Passwort eingegeben hast, im Arbeitsspeicher im Klartext verfügbar.
Richtig, Samstagnachmittag, so sieht es aus. Also das ist natürlich auch ein Problem.
Ja, wenn du was anderes verwendest, hast du natürlich ähnlich geartete Zugriffe, was weiß ich.
Du hast ein selbst gehorchstetes Bitwarn und irgendjemand bekommt Zugriffe darauf, was auch immer.
Also das sind so prinzipiell die zwei größten Probleme, die du hast. Und das kannst du eigentlich am besten umgehen,
indem du erstens nie deine Passwörter, egal was die versprechen, in die Cloud legst.
Aber wenn der Passwort Vault unverschlüsselt ist hinter einem langen Master Passwort steht, ist es trotzdem bedenklich klar.
Es ist immer bedenklich Cloud-Anbieter zu verwenden, weil woher willst du wissen, was der macht?
Du hast ein Webinterface oder eine App von diesem Anbieter. Du gibst da zwar dein Master Passwort ein,
was der aber im Hintergrund macht, das kannst du doch überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen.
Was okay ist, was du machen kannst, ist beispielsweise deine, wenn es unbedingt sein muss, du kannst deine Keypass-Datenbank
über Google Drive zum Beispiel sünden, wenn du das unbedingt machen willst.
Das würde funktionieren, aber der beste Schutz davor, dass man irgendwelche Sachen abgreift,
ist ja immer noch, wenn man sie erst gar nicht irgendwo hoch lädt.
Na doch, Open Source hilft, aber du kannst zum Beispiel an der, also selbst wenn der Anbieter sagt,
wir setzen auf Open Source-Technik und hier ist unser Source Code auf GitHub.
Du hast doch gar keine Ahnung, ob das, was der Anbieter auf GitHub hat, wirklich auch die Software ist,
die bei ihm gerade auf der Seite, die du benutzt, verwendet wird.
Also wenn du einen Cloud-Anbieter hast, wo du deine Passwörter in irgendeiner Art und Weise
dort in einem Formular oder sonst wo im Klartext eingeben musst, dann ist die Möglichkeit das abzugreifen,
da du weißt nicht, was die im Hintergrund machen und es ist ganz einfach, nie einen Cloud-Anbieter verwenden.
Das ist ganz im Prinzip das naheliegendste und offensichtlichste, was man nicht machen sollte.
Keine Cloud-Anbieter verwenden. Einfach keinem Cloud-Anbieter die Passwörter geben.
Also das sind so die zwei großen Probleme, die du mit Passport-Manager hast.
Die Variante, was du dagegen machen kannst, ist relativ easy.
Du nimmst halt was, was nicht in der Cloud ist.
Ich meine damit wie gesagt Cloud-Anbieter, die explizit Passport-Safes anbieten.
Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst deine Keypass-Datenbank sinken oder
irgendwelche Sachen, die du persönlich lokal verschlüsselt hast, die kannst du über Dropbox, Google Drive oder sowas schon sinken.
Das ist kein Ding. Die hast du ja lokal eingegeben, lokal verschlüsselt und du weißt, niemand konnte den Kram abgreifen.
Wenn du ein ordentliches Passwort hast, kannst du die sinken über Dropbox und Google Drive.
Ich meine die beste Variante ist natürlich immer noch, du sinkst die gar nicht über Google Drive, sondern irgendwie anders, dass das funktioniert.
Ich rede jetzt explizit über Cloud-Passport-Manager-Anbieter.
Also die auf gar keinen Fall verwenden.
Und das nächste ist Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Also wenn ihr was wie sagen wir mal, Keypass verwendet, Bitwarn oder was auch immer.
Was lokal läuft und was ihr vielleicht selbst sinkt oder erst nachdem ihr es verschlüsselt habt über die Cloud sinkt.
Das in Kombination mit Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Das ist eigentlich somit das beste was du malen kannst.
Es gibt da zig Sachen um das auszubauen.
Ja, Ubiqui, es gibt ähnliche Produkte.
Es gibt alle möglichen Sachen.
Man kann auch, ganz abgedreht kann man auch drei-Faktor-Authentifizierung machen.
Man braucht sein Master-Passwort.
Man braucht ein USB-Stick mit irgendeinem Key-File drauf.
Und man braucht eine SMS aufs Handy oder sowas.
Man kann das beliebig weiter spinnen alles.
Und Speichelprobe und irres Scannen.
Ja, kannst du alles machen. Man kann das möglichst weit.
Aber da hat man auch wieder die Gefahr.
Und das ist das was ich bei uns auf der Arbeit auch schon öfters gesagt hab.
Das Problem ist, wenn du es zu sicher und zu komplex machst,
fangen die Leute an sich Umwege zu suchen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Passwort-Richtlinie machst,
ihr dürft, keine Ahnung,
ihr müsst mindestens 20 Stellen verwenden.
Keine Zeichen doppelt haben.
Groß, klein, Sonderzeichen.
Ihr dürft die Passwörter nicht in den letzten zehn Mal ähnliche Passwörter verwenden.
Also wenn du übertrieben komplizierte Passwort-Vorgaben machst,
was passiert dann?
Die Leute suchen sich erst mal was möglichst Simples,
was die Passwort-Angaben erfüllt.
Aber halt für den Arsch.
Sowas wie 123456789, 123456789A Underscore oder irgendwie sowas.
Gut, das ist aber noch nicht so schlimm.
Das Schlimmste ist dann, wenn man sagt, okay,
wir gängeln euch jetzt so,
dass ihr euch den Scheiß gar nicht mehr merken könnt,
dann wird ein Zettel an Monitor geheftet.
Oder es wird ein TXT-Datei abgelegt
auf irgendeinem Server,
pw.txt, weil du den öfters brauchst.
Also das ist so,
irgendwann beißt sich Sicherheit selbst in den Arsch.
Weil irgendwann ist
zwar theoretisch die Sache noch noch sicherer,
aber so der menschliche Faktor dabei macht es dann wieder unsicher.
Und dann haben die Leute halt pw.txt auf irgendeinem Server draufliegen.
Ist bei uns auch...
Kein Witz, wir hatten auf der Arbeit
mal ähnliches Security-Probleme.
Es war keine pw.txt.
Und ich will das jetzt nicht zu sehr ausführen,
aber es war die Kombination
eines nicht gepatchten Windows-Systems,
was erreichbar war
per VPN von einem Dienstleister aus.
Und auf diesem nicht gepatchten Windows-System
gab es einen lokalen Admin-User,
der sehr sehr easy war darauf zuzugreifen.
Und von da ging es dann weiter.
Also das ist alles schon passiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Admin-Admin war, keine Ahnung,
aber wahrscheinlich sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, also, ja, das stimmt schon.
Die Sache ist aber die,
sobald du über die Struktur
des Passworts das Bescheid weißt,
dann hast du ja immer Vorteile.
Also wenn du jetzt weißt,
derjenige verwendet nur diese 10 englischen Wörter,
dann findest du das relativ einfach raus.
Aber das weißt du ja nicht.
Das weißt du ja nicht.
Weil du könntest diesen Fall noch mehr vereinfachen
und sagen, du hast ihm über die Schulter geguckt
und dir das Passwort gemerkt.
Das weißt du nicht.
Sobald du Aussagen treffen kannst,
quasi über die Struktur des Passwortes,
dann bist du weg von einfachem Brute Force.
Und das ist ja auch das,
ab wann Verschlüsselungsverfahren,
sagen wir mal, als angreifbar oder geknackt gelten.
Das ist der Punkt, wenn man es schafft,
Brute Force deutlich zu reduzieren.
Also wenn man es schafft,
ich muss alles durchprobieren,
stimmt ja nicht.
Statistisch gesehen musst du nur die Hälfte
der möglichen durchprobieren.
Das ist ja klar.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Klick, klick, klick.
Haben wir eigentlich Monkas hier noch?
Als Emote?
Ja, haben wir noch.
Jetzt kommt die Hyper-Advanced-Konfiguration hier.
Ich erkenne auch nicht,
wie es am Ende funktionieren soll.
Ah, boah, das ist,
oh, das ist ja mal richtig,
richtig advanced.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So, und wie kommt er jetzt weiter?
Ah, Hi-Fat-Time.
Immerhin, immerhin, es funktioniert.
Das fällt wieder, das fällt wieder.
Oh, oh, oh.
Er ist zu fett.
Er ist hinten zu fett.
Jetzt aber, jetzt aber.
Oh, oh, oh, das sieht gut aus, das sieht gut aus.
Das sieht gut aus.
Und jetzt runter, und jetzt runter.
Fuck.
Oh, noch ein Level.
Ja, elegant ist was anderes, das stimmt schon.
Sag mal, das funktioniert besser als das davor, oder?
Das funktioniert besser als das davor.
Zingler, danke für den Zap.
Ja, das funktioniert besser.
Guck mal, das läuft richtig auf den Dingern.
Oh, oh, oh, nice.
Klapper.
Jetzt fährt er rum, rum.
Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Falls wir mal, falls wir mal über eine Mauer klettern müssen mit dem Auto,
dann wissen wir jetzt, wie wir das bauen können.
Wieder was fürs Leben gelernt hier.
Wie sieht es bei Level Cap aus? Gibt es this Week in Gaming?
Nein, Level Cap will uns heute nicht jebaiten.
No, jebait.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Battlefield Friends.
Es gibt ein neues Battlefield Friends.
Das ist das einzige Battlefield Friends, was es nach dem Release gegeben hat, oder?
Ja, es gab eins zu Release.
Es gab eins zu Release.
Und jetzt das und das war's.
Hast du Linus Tech Tips ein Peter Bein Flash Storage gesehen?
Oh nee, hat er wieder irgend so ein unsinniges Ding gebaut, was kein Mensch braucht?
Und woran er dann wieder ein halbes Jahr später ein Video drüber machen kann?
We have lost all our data.
Das ist ja bei Linus mittlerweile schon so ein Standard Ding.
Der baut irgendwelche unsinnigen Storage Server und ein halbes Jahr später kommt wieder sowas in die Richtung wie
Guys, we need to talk about blablabla, wir haben die Daten verloren auf dem Storage Server.
Nein, da hätte ja nie jemand mit rechnen können.
Zeig mal her.
Der Internet Historian ist am Start.
Das ist ein neues Video.
Pock, das müssen wir gucken.
Der hat immer richtig nice Pock-champige Videos.
Der Internet Historian.
Taugt das?
Das sind die Videos eigentlich alle immer richtig gut gewesen von dem.
Wie kann Linus bei Raid 5 oder Raid 10 Daten verlieren?
Ach, bei Raid 5, gerade bei Raid 5 ist Daten verlieren relativ easy.
Wenn deine Parity, wenn deine, ähm, dein Parity, äh, deine, ähm, wie heißt denn das bei Raid 5?
Also wenn eine Platte abkackt bei Raid 5 und beim Rebuild eine andere, dann ist alles weg.
Das geht relativ easy bei Raid 5 Daten zu verlieren.
Heckgefahr.
Bei Kaspersky.
BSI warnt vor russischem, ja, die warnen aber nicht, das ist nichts Neues.
Also, vielleicht ist es nichts Neues.
Ich glaube, ich weiß um was es geht.
Die, das BSI warnen vor Kaspersky nicht weil es Russen sind, sondern, ähm, also nicht weil die denken das sind Hacker-Russen,
sondern weil es irgendwie Probleme gibt mit Updates oder irgendwie sowas glaube ich.
Also, das ist, das ist nichts was irgendwie, ähm, das ist glaube ich nichts was, was, weil man denkt Kaspersky kann man nicht trauen.
Wobei ich Kaspersky nicht trauen würde, aber trotzdem.
Wir gucken jetzt den Internet Historian.
Der ist Pog, Poggisch ist der, Poggisch, Pogchemisch.
Die Zone betwischen Area 50 und Area 52, also quasi Area 51.
Was ist eigentlich aus dem, was ist eigentlich aus dem, aus diesem, ähm, Ding geworden, wo die Leute Area 51 stürmen wollten mit Naruto Style Running und sowas.
Die sind alle abgezogen, oder?
Das war doch vor ein paar Jahren.
Ach, darum geht's.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns das an.
Das, das war doch vor zwei Jahren oder so, oder drei Jahren, wo nichts rausgekommen sei.
Okay, schauen wir uns das an.
Alter.
Alter, MonkaS.
Also, bei der Gelegenheit möchte ich noch mal darauf hinweisen, wir wissen ja alle, das ist ja allgemein bekannt, dass, ähm, Obamas Bodyguard ein Echsenmensch war.
Das wisst ihr alle, hoffe ich, oder?
Das ist euch allen klar, hoffe ich, das ist Allgemeinbildung ja mittlerweile schon fast.
Zuckerbeer, ja bei ihm ist die Sache eh vorbei.
Definitiv, gut.
Da sind, nur, dass wir, nur, dass wir auf einer Welt, denke ich, sind, ja.
Area 51
Ja.
Alright, that's it, folks. Good night.
These revelations were sent out all over the globe using beams.
Absolutely free.
Was genau passiert eigentlich in dem Video gerade?
It started an incredible awakening, inseminating the people's brains with knowledge.
Who killed JFK?
Flooring them with the revelation of it all.
An orangutan with a spear.
And soon they were bursting with righteous curiosity.
Bigfoot is a human-animal-hybrid.
Alright, here's the Google searches for Area 51.
Das war das Mischnis.
Spike, there, that's when Joe Rogan put out his podcast. You get the idea.
And you see, it reached the right man at just the right time.
A 21-year-old named Matthew Roberts.
He had heard about aliens in Area 51 before.
And he believed.
He wanted to see them.
Real bad.
But what could he do?
How could he possibly get into Area 51 to check him out?
Ding. Ding. Ding. Ding.
Scenario one.
If I ran into Area 51, I would be shot.
Die Naruto-Runners sind am Start.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
We'd both be killed.
But scenario three.
If there were so many of us, thousands, so much fodder that they eventually ran out with bullets.
Then someone, surely, is gonna get through and touch the government in its special area.
My god.
Within minutes, he was drafting a Facebook post.
They can't stop all of us.
I'm willing to die for the government. Let's do this.
On September 20th, 2019, we'll all meet up at the Area 51 Alien Central Tourist Attraction.
War das am Ende nicht so, dass da vielleicht, dass da irgendwie am Ende 20 Leute waren oder so?
Da war doch kaum einer.
And coordinate our entry.
If we Naruto-Run, we can move faster than their bullets.
Let's see them aliens.
This event then goes into the ether.
And from here, it was up to the Facebook algorithm gods to decide what would happen next.
There's a lot here to be excited about.
I think this could be very positive.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn es, wenn jemand sagt, Obamas Bodyguard ist ein Exenmensch.
Und danach Mark Zuckerberg ist ein Exenmensch.
Ich glaube eher das Letztere, wenn ich mir die Leute so angucke.
Der sieht schon so aus.
Also bei ihm würde ich das sofort glauben.
Man kann einfach davon abgehen, dass das alles Schwachsinn ist.
Aber vielleicht auch beides true.
Man weiß ja nicht.
People from all across the flat world were receiving the invite.
And they began pressing the attending button.
Was wer?
Ach Moment, ist das nicht diese Sekunde Chat?
Ist das nicht diese Porno-Darstellerin, die die Leute mit irgendwelchen NFTs gescampt hat?
War da nicht was letztens?
Wer hatte eigentlich noch kein NFT-Scam?
Sogar fucking Ozzy Osbourne hat NFTs mittlerweile.
Und man sich fragt, was ist mit euch los?
War das nicht der andere?
Kann auch sein.
Ich weiß nur, dass irgendjemand, irgendeine Porno-Darstellerin hat Leute mit NFTs gescampt.
Google mal.
Naja, ich habe gerade auf dem zweiten Bildschirm gegoogelt.
Das war keine gute Idee.
Ich weiß auch immer.
Ich kann danach jetzt nicht googeln.
Das ist zu Toss.
Ich schaue weiter.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die ich lange nicht mehr gehört habe.
Facebook-Geburtstagspartys.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Vor ein paar Jahren, wo die Leute Geburtstagspartys auf Facebook gepostet haben, auf einmal waren
500 Leute da.
Da hört man auch wenig von in letzter Zeit.
Das mag vielleicht daran liegen, dass die ganzen Zoomer, die sowas angesprochen haben,
mittlerweile kein Facebook mehr verwenden.
Within
just a couple of days, the event had picked up hundreds of thousands of attendees.
People loved the idea so much, they began making memes about how they were going to raid
the base.
So many, I can barely show you a fraction of them, rapid firing them out like the bullets
that would soon be gunning them down.
And so the event spread and spread around the Internet, eventually morphing into everyone
who reads something, it's going to raid Area 51.
Young people from all over the globe are joining up to fight for the future.
Die ganzen Autorunners, so geil.
Nigel, a runner.
No pointer.
Runner.
Steve, agent.
Simon, a runner.
Freeman, 713.
I am a sentinel.
Everyone's doing their part.
Are you?
We have the ships.
We have the weapons.
Captain, I'm going to put this gun down.
We need soldiers.
We need you all.
And just like that, the game was on.
Wir sind so durchgeknallt alle.
What?
Oh nein, please, nicht Nordfonds p.n.
To be or Nord to be.
Plans disappear, dreams take over.
I live, I laugh, I Nord.
Nord on every device like a blank canvas, I can be here and anywhere.
Jan, a man, a fortune.
Will you break these chains?
But wherever I go, there you are.
Nordvpn.com slash internethistoria.
No, thanks.
Look, I just-
Hey, hey, hey, hey, there's just an idea.
I know which one.
You want the female audience and I know women.
Good morrow to you, m'ladies.
Have you heard about-
Ich weiß, er gibt sich wenigstens ein paar bissel lauten Mühe.
Nordvpn.
You should get access to the international Netflix catalog.
Never miss another episode of the handsome man show.
Oh, don't you hate it when your dishwasher gets region locked?
No more.
Oh, I feel so safe in Nordvpn's big strong arms.
Especially with their new product, threat protection.
It protects me from malicious sites and downloads and trackers and intrusive ads.
Jaja, ganz bestimmt.
Think Nordvpn.com slash internethistorian, because the V in VPN stands for-
Region locket dishwasher ist nicht abwegig.
Nee, das ist nicht abwegig.
Nachdem Druckerhersteller mittlerweile Drucker deaktivieren können, weil einer seine Tinte
nicht bezahlt hat, ist nichts mehr abwegig.
I think we've heard enough.
Fine.
Alright, I'll do the ads you like.
Get Nord.
You could use some threat protection.
Take your online safety more seriously.
Ah, have you heard about their amazing prices?
Who beat me in Nordvpn slash internethistorian?
Ja, es ist gut jetzt.
Wir haben es verstanden.
Add or over?
Welcome to the mission brief.
Let's do a bit of background on Area 51.
Secret military base, first developed in 1955.
This is what it looks like on Google Maps.
It's approximately this big.
Total area size?
51.
50.
Total area size?
51.
And the volume...
Warum weiß man eigentlich, wo Area 51 ist, wenn es so top secret ist?
Es kommt mir gerade so hin.
Ist das überhaupt, was man auf den Bildern sieht, wirklich Area 51?
Until 1997, the government refused to even acknowledge that it existed.
That is, until they were forced to by lawsuit.
That lawsuit was about the death of two men who were former employees.
And how did they die?
Well, not aliens, but rather toxic fumes from burning garbage.
So what they would do is burn a whole bunch of cool high-tech refuse on the lot, let the
deadly smoke blow down wind, and the staff were stuck breathing it in.
Few years later, bing bing bong, cancer.
Other than that, the public hasn't really been told anything, so all people can do is
speculate as to what the hell is going on in there.
I think that they are keeping remnants of a UFO there.
We don't know if it's aliens, we don't know if it's time travel, we don't know if there's
minions in there.
A virtual reality that seems to be incredibly sexy.
But what has been leaked is that they do test flights on new alien crafts.
Motherfucker, don't you tease me.
Come on.
Alter, was bin ich... was bin ich sehen in diesem Video diesmal?
Also das mit der Concordia, da konnte man der Sache irgendwie noch folgen, aber diesmal
ist mega wild, Alter.
Produce new alien tech.
Breathe the latest version of the newest gayest fraud.
Do not get it confused with Roswell, that's over here, Area 51 is over here.
And the final thing that we know is that security is top notch, they have that thing locked
down.
Ja, das haben so secret bases Ansicht, dass man da nicht einfach rein kann.
So, do you wanna break in anyway?
Okay.
But that's gonna require some research.
And the first thing to find out, has anyone ever tried breaking in before?
Yes.
Several times.
In fact, in January of 2019, an unnamed man broke through security barriers and drove
eight miles into the base.
He got out of his car with a metal cylinder in his hands and the military opened fire.
He was shot dead at the scene.
And there was this time when a film crew from the BBC was arrested for trying to get in.
This is BBC news.
This time when a vacationing family of four went off track, you get the idea, they're
not messing around.
Put your fucking hands off, I'm not gonna tell you again.
But there's one story to top them all.
Bei den Amis würde ich mir da auch echt Gedanken machen, also wenn ich da so einen
vor mir stehen hab, dann würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch wirklich machen, was der sagt.
He'll disguise his identity, but he is my personal hero.
The month is November, the location Las Vegas, and the protagonist, a professional limo driver.
Now he's more than a little unhinged.
He decides to start harassing and sending death threats to a lawyer, whom we think was
gonna represent his defense for this incident.
If you've ever seen this TikTok, what the fuck, that's our boy doing donuts and driving
backwards down the Las Vegas strip.
Anyway, fast forward three weeks.
It's like six in the morning and this guy is already doing donuts at a car park near the
airport.
Then he decides to drive from the car park into the airport itself.
Offense?
No problem.
He drives right through it and onto the runway.
He's just driving around, whizzing between planes, almost crashing several times before
actually parking on a ramp.
At this point, he jumps out, puts on a clown mask, and storms right up to a private jet.
He announces, aggressively, to the flight staff that there is a bomb in his limo.
Quote, I have a fucking bomb, I'm going to blow this place up.
Oh, das ist schlecht zu sagen, das ist ganz schlecht zu sagen.
Also wenn du sowas sagst auf dem Flughafen, dann lebst du wahrscheinlich nicht lang.
His plan? To commandeer this private jet and take it to Area 51.
However, as sound as this plan was, the quick response by police meant that it wasn't really
working out.
So he bails back to his limo, tries to make an escape until eventually police catch up
with him.
Was für ne Neute?
He is quickly arrested.
They take him in for questioning.
Der kann ja froh sein, dass sie ihn nicht erschossen haben.
And he starts telling them, that's right.
I did it to see the aliens.
He also told them to refer to him as the chosen one.
And by the way, I have high security clearance.
Also I'm involved with the mob.
And someone owes me millions of dollars.
Later on, the bomb defusal crew checks out the limo and determines that it's just a fire
extinguisher with a bunch of wires and duct tape and some fairy lights.
Na gut, kann halt nicht jeder sowas bauen.
Now at some point he gets out, presumably on bail, and CNN reporters walk up to him
and start asking him questions.
No, no statements from me, he says, but you should talk to my lawyer.
And then he proceeds to hand them the business card of the lawyer that he's been sending
death threats to for the last three weeks.
Amazing.
After all that, the judge will be sent to a mental hospital for assessment.
Jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Okay, so people have really died trying to do this.
That means we're gonna have to be a little more covert.
So over at Area 51 HQ, the military can see that Facebook numbers have reached one million.
And it doesn't take a genius to calculate that even if just one percent of them show up,
that's...
Wait a minute.
Was sind das?
This many people.
In a crowd that big, there's bound to be at least a few who do something stupid.
In fact, the military took it so seriously that they even went over the nuances of Naruto
running.
Das ist doch jetzt getrollt, oder?
Das kann doch nicht ernsthaft sein.
Das kann doch nicht wirklich so sein, oder?
Das ist doch bestimmt cheap, ey.
Das ist doch jetzt cheap.
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Das kann doch nicht ernsthaft sein.
Das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Set to take place in Rachel, Nevada, a town that just so happens to neighbour Area 51.
It has 50 total residents and practically no infrastructure.
Perfect. Yeah, nice try, fellas, said the military.
And the captains and the generals all started planning their own EDM party.
With the deep state. Three groups in particular.
Introducing Group E, the E local state police.
Police have their work cut out for them because, owing to this party,
they think there could be upwards of 50,000 people descending upon the little town of Rachel.
Lincoln County commissioners trying to tackle the tough task of preparing for a potential inundation of people.
Sheriff Kerry Lee has less than 30 deputies.
The county declares a state of emergency and they allocate an extra $250,000 worth of enforcement for the weekend of the raid.
As well as an extra 300 police officers and paramedics.
That many people are going to stress the community.
Waren da nicht am Ende kaum Leute da?
To the point that we can't cope with it.
This is some of the most exciting stuff that I've ever gotten to work on.
Also bei ihm habe ich ja prinzipiell das Problem. Alles was er sagt wirkt so, als glaubt er das selbst noch nicht mal.
Also ich finde, Mark Zuckerberg ist so eines der unglaubhaftesten Personen, die es überhaupt gibt.
Egal was er sagt, ich kauf ihm kein Wort ab.
Hold on Mark.
I'm going to take out my gun and shoot somebody.
The FBI agents that showed up, they showed up at 10 a.m.
They contacted my mom.
So she texted me, she's like FBI is here, answer your phone.
I was kind of scared at this point.
This report from the Nevada Department of Public Safety was released last year and it features some very interesting details.
For example, they caught a group of YouTubers trying to plant a tracker on the bus that goes to and from the base.
We're going to pull an epic prank.
Highly illegal.
And you may not be that surprised to hear that the military isn't actually that worried about people breaking into the base.
Turns out they have automated weapons.
Not automatic weapons, automated, whatever that is.
Instead, they think there's potential that real terrorists will, you know, do the thing or a thing.
So counter-terrorism was given a budget to sweep a chemical, biological, radiological and explosive material.
Also im Prinzip haben sie ziemlich alles dort.
Nothing was found.
And there's just one last group getting involved as well.
The corporate press.
Das ist information agents in the mainstream media were getting involved.
They immediately started warning people not to raid use of lethal.
Wenn du wenn du Leute sagst, sie sollen es nicht machen, dann wissen wir, was in der Regel passiert.
Authorized spouting contempt for the stormers.
What started as a joke?
Facebook event quickly turned into a phenomenon.
Well, it began as a joke, but now it's turned into something much more serious.
Astroturfing campaigns by late night haha man number one through seven.
It's much more likely they'll see them tasers.
Ha ha ha, laugh it all up.
It's just a big joke.
People who say they're interested just keeps growing.
Faster than their bullets.
Let's see them aliens.
And they weren't afraid to give some of the biggest, brainest takes you've ever heard.
It's not clear the 1.1 million Facebook followers who said they're going to storm Area 51 are real and not Russian bots.
You're a god damn genius.
We'll make you take us seriously.
Let the training begin.
And speaking of that, I think it's time for my workout.
And so the Raiders began training.
We train for Area 51, so let's go.
They began pushing their bodies.
Pushing their wills.
Dass das schon wieder zwei Jahre her ist.
Pushing their spirits.
Pushing their minds.
Drei Jahre her ist.
Pushing their friends and family's patience.
To the left.
Who wants to call me to kick some alien butt?
In September, join me.
We out.
And that's what fitness will be like in the Metaverse.
As we zero in on the day of the raid, the count is up to 2 million attendees and that puts us on par with the world's largest standing army.
To coordinate all of these troops, we'll need a battle strategy.
Lay it on us.
From r slash memes, Intel was being filtered down to the troops.
Troops such as the Minecraft YouTubers.
The Normans.
The Weaves.
Facebook Moms.
Files.
Chads.
Crackheads.
Is this a 5 o'clock free crack giveaway?
Florida Man.
The Australians.
The gay Reddit mods.
Okay, this thread is locked.
And the North Korean defectors.
They all had their role to play.
So, Godzilla comes in from the East while the Australians make a distraction.
That allows the minion cosplayers to breach from the South.
Of course, these very serious strategies would have to be disguised as memes.
So that they could be spread across YouTube, Reddit and TikTok without the threat of being...
Although, not everyone was as tech savvy.
Authorities managed to nab one of them.
In cartographers.
And they pressured him into an interview on the television.
It took me a total of five minutes to put this image together.
It was sort of like a battle strategy almost.
Doch so viel.
It was completely rooted in satire.
That was just completely rooted in satire.
And no one should raid.
This is just completely a joke.
And completely just a joke.
Mission counting sheeple complete.
You can take them out.
Okay, so remember how we're not raiding anymore and it's just a music festival?
Wink, wink, wink, wink.
Well, bad news.
Okay, so it sounds like maybe you're looking at changing venues.
Possibly.
It's all up in the air.
We're putting Matty on the spot here.
There's a lot of challenges.
But it's two weeks away.
It's kind of going to figure it out, I guess, somewhat soon, right?
Yeah, it's all kind of falling apart.
See, Matty too wirklich in irgendwelchen Talkshows hat.
Organized alien stock with a few other people.
But his main business partner was Connie West.
I didn't plan it.
It planned me.
But Matthew is the headliner.
His name is attached to everything.
And he's starting to get worried about a fire festival type situation in the desert.
Be a fire fest 2.0.
He wanted to make sure there's plenty of water, food, security, insurance, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And here, deals and communications start to break down.
Eventually there's a lawsuit and it's kind of boring.
Things that they were supposed to pay for, I'm stuck paying for.
Who cares?
We're going to skip it.
But the TLDR is that they had a disagreement and Connie said...
I don't have to prove to you what I said.
You didn't sign a fucking contract with me to begin with.
So that's why...
Wollten die wirklich ein Festival?
Ich dachte, das Festival war bloß zur Ablenkung.
Ich blinke nicht mehr durch.
Das ist mir zu advanced mittlerweile.
I don't need to prove to you a motherfucking thing.
And Matthew said...
Matthew then took $70,000 worth of sponsorship money and declared alien stock in Rachel canceled.
Was, was, was?
Was hat denn Pornhub damit jetzt schon wieder zu tun?
With the sponsorship money and declared alien stock in Rachel canceled.
But then, at the same time, Bud Light walks in.
It's the Bud Night.
We're saved.
They say, hey, why not do it here?
In the Vegas.
It has plenty of lighting, indoor plumbing.
It has everything.
Matthew said yes.
And then, using the website for alien stock, he told everyone to not go to Rachel and instead to go to Vegas.
Welcome to alien stock Las Vegas.
Sponsored by Bud Light.
And also Pornhub, but it's a long story.
Connie was left to pick up the pieces.
However, she would not be discouraged so easily.
She decided to press on.
It's gonna be a great party.
No matter what, it's gonna be a great party.
She had to take full control of the event in Rachel.
Dipping into her savings and even mortgaging.
Warum gibt es jetzt zwei Events?
Ich denke, die sind alle nur zur Ablenkung gedacht.
Boom.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
I think this is a liability.
I'm out.
So is it clear what's going on?
Nein.
It's worth doing a very fast recap because there's an event in Rachel that's been declared canceled, but also not canceled.
Also I forgot to mention there's an event in HECO that isn't canceled, but it will be on the second day.
There's also that third festival in Las Vegas, which has the former promoter of the first one and they both share the same damn name.
And none of this has anything to do with the actual raid on Area 51, which is here, which has several gated entrances by the way, and none of them have been declared the official gathering point.
Confused?
Yeah, pretty much everyone was.
It's a god damn mess.
People, rightfully, put the whole thing in the too hard basket and instead of going to one in the middle of nowhere, just went to the one in Vegas.
Let's fast forward to the weekend of the raid.
For better or worse, Rachel is about to open its doors to the Millennials.
Hell yeah!
Aliens!
Encore now has come to an abrupt halt.
Don't let the aliens get you, Ken.
Do you believe in aliens?
I don't.
Ron, get out of here!
Oh, you know, I want to hear about the alien liberal agenda.
They could have some good talking points, but we don't know.
To protect my mind from interference.
Is das jetzt wirklich echtes Footage von diesem Event?
So viel ist da jetzt aber net los.
Wander.
Don't let me leave, Murph!
It could do anything, Stank, but it's alien stuff.
How do you see walking with that shirt up over your head like that?
I don't.
The first ones are supposed to be all these, you know, the best ones.
Paranormal lawyer.
PhD level...
Ich blick mich mal durch.
In downtown Las Vegas, did they change the name or is it still alien stock?
I think I'm on my highest high I've ever been in my life.
Look at it.
And we are taking a look kind of the area here.
You've done a lot of work in a very short period of time.
The security is here.
The medical's here.
The food is here.
The people are here.
And most importantly...
Wenn du 50 Einwohner gewohnt bist, ist wahrscheinlich, wenn mal 200 da sind, geht's richtig ab.
Toilets are here. Toilets, haha, well done. Yeah, it was pretty good. I just went through a breakup, guys.
Well, it wasn't quite the event that they had hoped for, but they did do a commendable job of acting retarded for the news.
This is the most fun I've ever had in my life. Do you think of yourself as being around?
I do. Here for scientific reasons. Alter, das sind jetzt nur die komplett Verrückten hin, oder?
This is like the most millennial thing that's ever happened. Ach du Scheiße.
Don't let's forget. Hiko, or the Haiko. No one knows how to pronounce it.
This event was being hosted by George Harris of the Alien Research Center.
The owner of the center is Las Vegas businessman George Harris, creator of Alien Tequila.
You want to have fun. If you want to have a great look, it's a great day.
Basecamp was equipped with a vendor village of 10 food trucks, a gift shop and three time Grammy Award winner Paul Oakenfold for some reason.
I was told there's a lot of people coming. Well, right now things are kind of slow at the Haiko event here, so that's kind of a disappointment.
Hiko Basecamp was expecting somewhere between 1,000 and 20,000 attendees.
And in the end it was... Maybe 50 people here. Super. Where's the cheats? Where's the cheats?
This is like the first of a big thing. Ah, but it wasn't. 50 Leute, not so many.
In fact, it seems as though the majority of the attendees were actually the press.
One lady believed that her parents is actually aliens.
So after the first night they decided to cut their losses and cancelled the whole event.
You know, the producers of the show, it's very, very, very expensive. And it just didn't make sense.
Because basically all of the attendees were stolen by...
Alien stock 2019.
We were going to go out to Rachel and then we decided that we didn't want to get stuck in the desert. As much as I like Mad Max, I don't want to live it.
The Las Vegas alien stock, sponsored by Bud Light, was a smash hit. They've got carnival rides, photo ops.
Was hat es denn jetzt noch mit der eigentlichen Sache zu tun? Nix, oder?
Video games and even a pool. No running.
Who could have predicted this? You make a post at 2 a.m. on a page that has 62 likes and now you have thousands of people that are ready to come out to your show. It's absolutely amazing.
Back of military HQ in Anor Londo, operations were ramping up.
They're adding more guards, upping the security and enforcing a no-fly zone across the county.
They were even infiltrating raider groups.
You could be standing next to an officer and not even know it. There was a big undercover presence here.
And they were giving stern warnings from the PR team. They posted this tweet.
The last thing millennials will see if they attempt to raid Area 51 today.
Sorry to disappoint you, Yugi. You triggered my trap card.
Millennials immediately seized upon the tweet, doing what they do best by pretending to be offended, successfully having the tweet taken down and forcing a public apology.
I'm retarded.
Alright, this video is getting very long. Let's hurry up to the main event.
Ja, da war nichts. Da ist doch nichts gewesen. Ich kann mich nur noch dunkel dran erinnern, aber da war doch keiner mehr. Also kaum Leute.
Außer ein paar, die sinnlos vor der Kamera Naruto runnend haben. Hey, are you coming? Ja.
Wo alle geblitzt denkst, genau.
Wie geht's dir? Na dann, was willst du tun? Ich habe die Tür geöffnet. Die Gegner sind in der Nase. Ich werde sie jetzt schützen.
Ach du Scheiße.
Was passiert hier? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe legit keinen Plastenschimmer.
Ich werde sie jetzt schützen.
Ist klar.
Ja, genau so war es.
Leaked footage.
Besser als Belleville 2042.
Die ganzen Weeps sind down. Weeps out.
So und jetzt, was wirklich passiert ist.